this is jaco podcast number 91 with echo
Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening and we are
rolling straight into QA today so
questions from the interwebs go Charles
go go okay first question
chuckle I've just finished about face
the book amazing book interested how you
modeled your style on Hackworth though
hack was a renegade and always bending
the rules to break to the breaking point
but in extreme ownership you talk about
for example not pushing back on higher
command when it came to Iraqi troops
have listened to podcast - but was
hoping you could go into it a bit more
yeah so I guess that's a good question
hack he was kind of considered a
renegade but but also he was also a
total company man you got to realize
that there's that dichotomy there's a
guy that hack loved the army he loved
the army he wanted his uniform would
look super squared away
he followed all the rules and
regulations that and he supported the
leadership all the time when the
leadership was right hmm and that's what
makes him a good renegade in my opinion
and I was very much the same way I was
all about the Navy you know I was all
about the games as a matter of fact Tony
you know what Tony used to say it was a
little thing we got going in to you
bruiser that spread around but of course
it came from Tony first which was all
Navy all the time would just be joking
about you know I think I don't know what
originally caused it but like guys would
make fun of me because I would wear like
jungle boots or Dan or boots out - on
Liberty with a pair of like old jeans
yeah cuz when you're when you're like
that kind of old just raised in the
team's you don't even know any different
and you're like oh well I'm going out
and I need to wear shoes cool where's my
jungle boots that's what you end up like
and and you're into it you're not like
you think it's good you think it's
normal play
the way things are designed and so I
supported the teams and HACC supported
the Army of course but this is the thing
if the leadership was wrong or there was
something being passed down that was
wrong and it was a big wrong like if it
was little I wouldn't be like oh man
this is crap they're making us to wear a
different pair of shorts now cuz like
that would happen like some new
commanding officer would come in and
change some thing right and sometimes we
could do that with dude be quiet you
know just be quiet
you know they're giving you new shorts
where are the new shorts you know oh
they're telling us we can't wear
baseball hats anymore cool don't worry
baseball hats yeah ain't some gospel the
truth who cares it's like they don't
care what I'm wearing on my head you
know like oh you want to issue it's
different ball caps to find whatever but
then if it was a larger issue then or
obviously if it was something that was
like actually wrong like criminally
wrong or morally wrong or something like
that then yeah I'd be like no we can't
do that so the reason that I didn't push
back on Iraqi troops and working with
Iraqi troops when we got to Ramadi was
because as I looked at it I realized
that it was the right thing to do and
yes it was gonna be more dangerous and
yes it definitely took us out of our
comfort zone but as I explained in
Xtreme ownership if we didn't train
those people up if we didn't train the
Iraqi soldiers and take them out and get
them fighting and get them squared away
on the battlefield then Americans would
have been doing it forever
so it was the correct call was to do
that now I've talked about the same same
thing when they told us a ratio mmm they
gave us a ratio of how many Iraqis we
had to have for everyone
Iraqi we had to have I don't know what
that I forgot that I was seven or for
every one SEAL we had to have seven
Iraqi soldiers they said that something
like that I forgot what the numbers were
and I said that doesn't make sense to us
cuz sometimes we only have 10 guys to go
out and I'm there's no way I'm sending
only one seal with ten Iraqis old
not noon it need a corpsman Nita
radiomen need the machine gunner need a
leader like that's what I need so and
when I pushed back because I didn't push
back against ball caps and because I
didn't push back against some stupid
uniform change they were like oh yeah
well that actually makes sense chakra we
don't want you to go in the field with
only one seal so I would clearly push
back if it was something that makes it
same thing with like the martial arts
training that they had us doing in the
in the late 90s and early 2000s it was
not good mm-hm and I was told everyone
hey this is not smart this is not good
this training is dumb we need to do
other training that's better and same
thing you know things go on like here's
another like stupid example they
wouldn't want to issue a platoon the the
radios you were gonna take on deployment
because they didn't want you to break
him or whatever and so they the issue
not enough radios for everyone and so
now that everyone doesn't know how to
operate the radios and you're basically
operationally testing the radios while
you're going through your workup so I
said hey this is garbage issue everyone
radios that's how we operate that's how
we need to train doctor so in the
training they wouldn't issue the radios
yeah there was like a time period we're
low on radios they said we're gonna keep
these radios for deployment it's that
doesn't make sense
yeah I got a good idea buy more radios
yeah so you know those are things I'd
push back on and you were always pushing
back on the type of training that was
gonna happen and who was gonna how
you're gonna run the training so when
something when it made sense to push
back I push back just like hackers did
now hackers did it on a massive scale
because he eventually pushed back on the
way the ward Vietnam was being run and
had I been smart enough and the war
didn't take the shift that it took and
we didn't move towards counterinsurgency
and we didn't make those adjustments
that the that Colonel MacFarland
implemented in Ramadi maybe maybe I
doubted maybe I would have been smart to
say hey we're not running this war right
we need to do something different and
running up the chain of command but but
at the time you know Colonel MacFarland
made great decisions
he led they had a great plan a great
strategy so I was 100%
but if you know Hackworth that didn't
happen they were not fighting correctly
against the Vietnamese and and they were
taking massive casualties for a hill
that two days later they've give back
hmm
and so he was saying what are you doing
and and the other thing you know when he
took over the hardcore battalion they
were fighting for months and they had
they had literally killed almost no any
I think it was a zero I think it was
actually zero enemy and yet they had
taken all kinds of casualties themselves
and so we seen this is wrong this is
wrong so I think that's that's what
being a leader is you support the stuff
you support the command yes of course
you support the command when it makes
sense and as long as it makes sense and
normally it's gonna make sense you know
I mean normally it's gonna make sense
not like the the Admirals and the
generals are saying hey how can we lose
this war let's come up with a stupid
strategy know they're doing the best
they can so it's not like it's a regular
occurrence I mean like I said when I was
working for Carter Colonel MacFarland he
was a smart guy he was a brilliant guy
that had a great strategy of I'm like
okay awesome
I'm here to support and and I'll tell
you when I did and this is I think this
is important is that even though I was
kind of a renegade and I was more
rebellious when I was a kid obviously I
was a I was young when I got to the SEAL
Teams then so you know when you were
pushing all those things that I said oh
we got to do this that was me when I was
at four in the SEAL Teams you know what
we go do that we should just be able to
do whatever we want you know we're just
stupid but as I got older I realized
that you need to you know come across as
a renegade quote-unquote to come across
as a big rebel that doesn't well
immediately when you go and push back on
something everyone just dismisses you oh
yeah jock oh he's just a loudmouth he
just he just pushes back against
everything he doesn't what he's won't do
everything his way no you want them to
say oh wow hold on a second if jock was
pushing back against this yeah
then this this must be something wrong
here because he doesn't push back
against stuff he tells the line all the
time so we should listen to him that's
what you want to build that's what I did
my best to build and that's how I think
it would be comparable to the way
Hackworth led and the way that I tried
to obviously I know
Acworth but I stole as much as I could
from him and the weird thing is I'll
tell you this I always say I stole from
him but it wasn't like I was sitting
there reading the book no I'm gonna do
what he did here I think it was just
absorbed and he didn't even the naming
of task unit bruiser like when I did it
I wasn't thinking this is what Hackworth
did but it was real obvious that that's
where I got it from like I didn't think
I'm gonna rename this indeed we're gonna
turn this thing around based on auto
would not turn around but we're gonna
build this based on no I was like you
know what we're not gonna be tasking at
Bravo because that sounds lame or maybe
task unit bruiser because that sounds
awesome
you know and and and then later you know
I look back I'm like oh god that's what
that's exactly what hack words that I
obviously stole it from him yeah so
appreciate it AK but that's what I'd say
BIA renegade but that should be that
should be in the background that should
be in the back of your mind in the front
of your mind should be hey I'm a
supporter of what's happening yeah kind
of like the willingness to be a renegade
if you have to yeah yeah if you have to
and believe me I've known all kinds of
good seals that were to renegade yeah
yeah just like I'm ironic yeah there's a
straight-up hey I'm a renegade and and
you know that just it the only guys that
could get away with that what guys that
were so ultimately operationally squared
away yeah that people go yeah you know
he's kind of a maniac but dude he's
really really good and really tactically
sound all that make it they make that
happen now
as you get more and more senior homie
don't play like after a certain point
it's done and you got to get you got to
play the game that's what you got to do
as you get more senior got to play the
game and from like your subordinates
viewpoint if if they look to me ankle Oh
Jacques was just playing the game he's
just doing it yes I am yes I am because
this way it gives me more ability to
control everything that's gonna impact
you people that work for me
so yes I'm gonna play the game so you
don't have to yeah you're welcome
so yeah jack
next question jiu-jitsu BJJ jiu-jitsu
during your time in Iraq if you like
please paint me a picture how to imagine
a BJJ class from you as an active
soldier did you have a key mats and how
would it differ from a quote-unquote
normal class so yeah I always brought
mass with me starting with 1998 I think
is when I started bringing mats with me
how do you bring math do you just be
like hey in military transport you build
something called a pallet alright pallet
and they're like 8 feet by 8 feet yeah
pretty big and you put stack all kinds
of stuff on them yeah and you know
you've got your weapons just whatever
you like you got your engines you got
your motors you got your motors you got
your boats your your zodiac boats you've
got paddles you got all this I mean all
the equipment and everyone's personal
gear is on there they're op dere their
body armor it's all on these big pallets
and when you go on deployment you'll
have 8 pallets 8 of these giant pallets
and so on some of those pallets there
would be mats so who is it up to though
you know you're talking about weapons
and zodiacs and stuff and and then yeah
it's like oh yeah move it up to
whoever's in charge which so then it
made it real easy yeah and and even if
it wasn't me I mean everybody you know
if people are bringing something to help
everyone get better yeah you know people
yeah yeah that's cool so is it a fact
provable process no man you can say like
this guy's bringing all kinds of crazy
things man
I remember guys you guys to bring
surfboards I mean they pack their
surfboards on pallets they'd hack you
weights and squat racks and anything
that you want if you're going on a
six-month deployment to a remote
location yeah you're gonna prefer your
load out of squat rack and a bunch of
bumper plates and if that remote
location has waves
you're packing surfboards if it has if
it has you know rock climbing you're
gonna pack rock climbing gear yeah
that's the I'm telling you this is one
of the things that it's really hard to
the SEAL Teams it's really hard to have
that I think we I think in the we in the
SEAL Teams have that
than most people it's just this this
autonomy to kind of make things happen
and do kind of cool stuff yeah and I'm
not saying no no one ever gets to do
that but you know III don't think a
regular army unit or regular Marine
Corps unit would be putting you know
seven surfboards on there yes so where
so where's the limit though like so what
can i let's say me who we're going can I
get a Leia TV can I get a TV TVs like a
big screen yeah yeah yeah it just do it
also depends on where you deploy what
you do and what the mission is cuz you
know my first time to Iraq we didn't
have much of any of this stuff obviously
right we just had our op gear basically
and but the second time the second time
I went to Iraq we brought more but we
actually add - well - squat rack it's
pretty awesome there's a third Marine
that there's a great marine that was
with us and he ran he manned the radios
and he was just a just a awesome guy and
he was he was a marine but he was there
was Marines across the river and so he
was supposed to keep continuity and he
got assigned to us anyways awesome guy
and he knew how to weld he was from a
farm up in Montana or something so he
knew how to weld and he had the gear and
we didn't have a squat rack and so our
Seabees because there's a bunch of
Stevie's with us yeah they got they were
able to like just come up with stuff
they did make anything happen my head CB
was just could see that's Seabees build
things and they also acquire things
combat builder it's it's a combat
engineer battalion it's a Construction
Battalion that's what it's so it's CB
for short but it's the Seabees and so
yeah they build things and they also are
very good at acquiring things you know
things just show up at your at your base
and my guys were awesome at acquiring
things and we didn't have a squat rack
which is which is crazy to me to be
having no squat rack right what why
don't you have a squat rack so yeah it's
ridiculous this this Marine welded a
squat rack now here's the interesting
part the squat rack he was he was tall
he was like maybe six 465 maybe not that
tall but even Banga the marine welder so
on this squat
there was you know there's adjustable to
put the bar on mm-hmm well this didn't
have adjustable things just had two
hooks and there was one hook at his
height or one set of hooks at his height
and one set of hooks at my ID everyone's
data figured out from there but but yeah
so yeah you could bring you could bring
that if you wanted to and so so yes we
brought Matz
I brought Matz on that deployment and
both actually both my deployments to
Iraq brought Matz and then one of the
class like well generally you're
training with people that don't know
anything and I would have trained with
them on the workup you know so they're
starting to learn and they're like you
know low-level white belts or mid-level
white belts are even high-level wipeouts
I don't think we I even had one blue
belt on even one of my deployments and
the good thing is they're team guys
they're athletic they're strong they're
in good shape they want to learn so they
learn fast they're tough there's like I
said strong and athletic so you got to
get good rolls yeah I mean want the more
you teach them the better the rolls get
talking about gear nogi we never try
never traveled with Aggie for the
military I don't think and so what-what
I started wearing almost all time was
Cammy pants and a t-shirt and what's
cool is I did that when I soon as I
started you did too I was training with
other seals that were in Cammy pants and
and a t-shirt because it didn't make
sense to wear like a Cammy top yeah and
so what's cool is without even knowing
it when no one was training noogie I was
actually training noogie because I did
was just training with guys with
t-shirts on not even wearing pants but
but anyways so yeah that's what we'd
wear Cammy pants and a t-shirt would we
occasionally put on top gear
occasionally but but not not very often
the other thing you got to watch out for
with with my former organization in the
SEAL Teams is there's guys that would go
nuts like they didn't want to tap
because you get major he goes and so
guys could occasionally go psycho
sometimes when I when I pit for certain
people against each other sometimes I'd
have to basically officiate slash be a
safety officer to make sure that no one
actually got killed because they'd be
trying to kill each other and no one
wants to happen after the game and you
can't know you're about to your arms
about to get broken stop so you had to
do some of that
and I'm I'm I am a bit of an instigator
yeah and when it could everything you
see it now I still do it on the mats
today you know I mean if if there's two
guys that are going hard against each
other but maybe they're not going super
hard yeah yeah they could go hard it's
real easy to escalate that answer and so
I would escalate matches between guys as
well and and then you know I just roll
with everyone so yeah with what the
class be like we teach the moves just
like a Drago jiu-jitsu class teach some
moves go over some stuff and then roll
and that's it pretty simple good times
yeah I found that if you can do little
drills with yourself if you go if you're
a high level guy and you're going with a
white belt especially if they're
athletic what you do is you know how
like when you roll with a guy who's
maybe one level give or take from you
you um or let's say they're one level
lower you'll kind of slowly put yourself
into better or worse situations you
won't go all out or nothing like yeah
but this is kind of counterintuitive to
if you go with like a like a beginner
beginner but they're athletic what you
do is you try to you think of a finish
or make you should do that yeah as fast
as you possibly can oh so if you're like
okay I'm gonna start on the box are
gonna force how many know well depends
on we're gonna have to force it yeah but
you're forced an arm lock if you say I'm
gonna finish this with an arm lock you
have to force him into that position
someone yeah yeah you can set it up sure
yeah exactly that's what that's really
the drill is that you gotta set it up
given what he does and he could be
retreating the whole time sure it's
gonna so it's gonna take longer it's
just that's just how should you do is
but that's the drill in your head rather
than you know you let's say an intuitive
method to roll with the white belt is
let's just go light let's see what he
does let him get a good position on you
and I don't work out but no don't do
that be like okay I'm gonna treat this
person like a person that I have to in
real life so do with and you choose
whatever that's a good game to play
actually that is a good game to play and
then you get real good at that going
from one thing and then it's also I
don't play that game very often I don't
know what there's something that snaps
in my head sometimes when I'm like okay
I'm gonna just smash this
but you know sometimes I'll be watching
the clock and when there's 40 seconds
left I'll be like alright I'm gonna try
and submit this do to the next 40
seconds or this is what I'm going
against someone that's good you know
what I mean that's honestly I do that
with you sometimes word you can feel me
chilling and I'm all of them like oh
wait there's a 30 seconds left and I
have to go super hard you try and get
you and sometimes I don't get myself
enough time and so they have to learn it
better yeah and yeah me saying that
agree I don't do that in training
because what I hardly my lazy instinct
is I always go just enough better than
the person I'm going against Tia to
maintain and eventually finish you see
and that's good because you give the
other guy good training yeah and that's
kind of the point with not you don't
want if you go in regular jusu class and
you're like you know upper belt mean
like purple brown black belt and you go
against a white belt you get paired up
with a white belt I'm not saying
necessarily to do that all the time
because it's kind of you kind of it's a
relationship you have with your training
partners so if I'm like okay every white
belt I go against or everything or any
beginner I'm just gonna go as hard again
it's like bro what are you doing through
the guy sure good that's why that's why
for what you're saying for blue belts to
do that is not good so who else is that
why else they don't have the skill yet
yeah yeah that's a brown belt black belt
yeah that's gonna be that's gonna be
like okay I'm gonna test my efficiency
on making this happen really quickly
yeah belt against a athletic white belt
it's gonna be it's gonna be World War
seven yeah and there's injuries that are
waiting to happen yeah cuz a purple belt
generally is not gonna get it injured
not gonna generally injure someone from
being in a bad position blue belt white
belt
yeah and and so really the point in
doing that is like in a scenario like
your situation where you don't have
anyone to train with except for
beginners that are all athletic and
hungry so it's like okay well what do I
do you know you know what school I would
come home from deployment better at
jujitsu
than when I left for sure that happened
on every deployment I came home I was
better at jujitsu than when I left but
not only better than I was
but I was in keeping with the standards
of the guys I was training with yeah
so you know I'm rolling with Dean before
I leave
and I come back and I am now doing
better than I was against Dean before I
left where he's been here training the
whole time so that that says to me that
is an effective way to train you know
you just you just and the that's why
there's really no excuse allowed people
ask you know what should I do I live
four hours away from the closest gym man
get some friends put some mats on the
ground watch YouTube and start training
with each other and occasionally when
you get the chance go somewhere to a
school once a month once every two weeks
so you can learn yeah yeah and I think
in your situation is is kind of a not
necessarily unique but kind of a
specific type of situation where you
have all the fundamentals essentially
down sure so you know like habitual
stuff stuff that you just automatically
do with certain techniques which is the
correct technique you know so you could
think that you'll benefit more in that
way where you can train with beginners
in training when I was a blue belt
myself yeah I still got a lot better
when I would be on deployment yeah when
I was a purple belt when I was a brown
belt yeah still still it's just like a
little just a smaller version of that
idea where if you're beginner and you're
like okay I'm never taking jiu-jitsu
them start on YouTube or whatever I
don't think you can benefit fellow
situations oh no you can decimal
initiative not as much
you can't yeah you can definitely not as
much but you can benefit I mean
definitely benefit you can definitely
benefit yeah it's better it's a thousand
times better than not doing anything and
not trained oh yeah and if you got one
person that has that gift of being able
to like understand what's happening
maybe you got a wrestler in there
Berlin's gonna help you so much or
you've got someone that did you don't
maybe that's gonna help you so much yeah
but even if you know what you just start
looking at it and saying okay what's
happening in this what's happening right
there okay try that arm walk on me and
you get some of those good youtube
videos that really break things down
well yeah I think you can cuz I didn't
have to learn that way luckily yeah yeah
luckily you got to train with the best
guys in the whole entire world
actually yeah actually Roger Gracie
who's you know we not even arguably top
three all-time yeah ever he and he is
actually telling me it's like I don't
have like
a team of world-class guys to train with
he's like sometimes I trained with
Braulio sometimes because he's in
England yeah so yeah it's like he's like
I only train with my students and who
are good and they give awesome training
but they're not I don't have world-class
trainer partners like my opponents do
kind of thing and yeah so man to kind of
teach their own but all these things
yeah can be beneficial even even if they
don't necessarily seem like it yeah you
know what I think actually this is
leading to is like you get what you make
out yeah yeah there's there's people in
the UFC that have done the same thing
that came from some random camp and
they're training hard and they go and
win the the Conor McGregor he didn't
come from
he didn't come from Greg Jackson you
know he didn't come from American Top
Team he came from a group you know their
school with Cavanaugh and obviously
they're doing something right but same
thing he didn't have the highest level
guys to train against he trained
I'm not saying slagging off they're
their training partners but it's not it
wasn't a known camp when he came around
he's so he's a guy like that max
Holloway he's out in Hawaii right he's
training hard but he's coming out here
winning the UFC championship based on
you know his training partners so I
think guys that that actually understand
what they need to do yeah they do it
they get it done they don't make any
excuses excuses yeah next question with
life decisions is it better to be
decisive and take actions to move
forward even if sometimes those
decisions are wrong as opposed to being
paralyzed by indecision and fear thus
getting maneuvered on by life I asked
this because I struggle with life
decisions and have trouble committing to
one path duty eclectic interests after
listening to your podcast I'm thinking
it's better to be aggressive and
maneuver on the battlefield of life as
long as I'm prepared to adapt rather
than sitting around and letting
circumstance dictate my actions well it
sounds like he kind of answered his own
question
good yes it is better to be aggressive
it's better to be decisive this does not
mean burning bridges and I think we've
talked about this before it doesn't mean
that you just you just say I'm quitting
my job right now because I'm gonna go
start a new life as a whatever your new
job is gonna be right I'm gonna start a
business selling widgets and I'm just
gonna go all-in
cuz I'm committed sure well you you know
how long does it take to produce those
widgets and whatever you know so there's
a lot of issues with that you know it's
there's a way though to to mitigate risk
on your decisions and actually at the at
the camp we were in up in Maine there
was a lot of guys that were you know
listen to the podcast and one of them
really good really good guy he was
talking about his business and the
business which I'm not gonna go into any
details but he's basically saying look I
got this business it's going well I
wanted to do better and I'm kind of
weighing this decision between bringing
on we said no I want to bring home like
six people mmm to really help expand and
grow and all that stuff he said but if I
do that and we have a couple rough you
know if we hit some bad luck I might be
upside down and and not be able to
handle it and and what I really am
scared of is like that's not just me but
it's now it's my family I got a wife and
I got kids and now I'm hedging the the
the comfort and safety of my family so I
don't know what to do and I said okay
well do you have to go all-in right do
you have to turn around tomorrow no you
know what we're going all-in I'm gonna
hire these six people we're gonna expand
and hopefully if everything goes right
we'll do really well mm-hmm you don't
have to do that you don't have to put
that much on the table instead I said I
said well how many people do you
actually really need right now and he
said probably one or two and I was like
okay why don't you bring on one and and
start to see where that goes and be
prepared to look for another person to
bring on too and then as those two
people work out and you're starting to
fill their labor every day and they're
having to have work to do because you're
expanding the cool bring on three
and guess what if you hit a hiccup and
things start going sideways for whatever
reason that's cool you don't have those
additional four people or three people
on board that you're paying payroll to
every month which is normally what kills
businesses or one of the common things
that kills businesses so it's the same
so that's that's a good example right
and he was he thought to himself when he
looked at me said absolutely I'm gonna
go do that and so he's probably back at
his job right now running his business
and probably hiring a person to start
expanding not hiring six people and
putting all of his chips on the table
where it's a cool gamble let's say the
percentage of living winning is 70%
you're like yeah I'm just gonna do it
there's a 30% chance you lose lose and
now you're now your family has no house
and no food so that's not what we want
to do so why not just put some of your
chips on the table and you can still win
and make a little bit you still you
still improve your position so we got to
do that with life - like I said you
don't quit your job to start building
widgets when you don't know what you're
doing you got a bit why not just build
the widgets in your spare time
yeah see what else yeah start putting
those things on the internet start
seeing how they sell start getting a
little income from them let them grow
and then finally when you feel like the
balance start to tip maybe there'll be a
last minute jump will you be like okay
now I'm gonna go for it
yeah but what you're committing to is
something solid something tangible and
something that's making money right
we're not jumping in and committing to
something that's an unknown we're gonna
commit some to something that's known
and and I think it's important to note
that that right there is not a lack of
commitment and this is your these like
you know people on the interwebs they'll
be like you know why you haven't made it
yet cuz you haven't committed a hundred
percent that's why you if you want to do
it you gotta commit with everything
you've got well and so what people think
is okay well I'm just gonna quit my job
because I'm gonna go for him to commit
and then I'll be successful because this
guy over here told me if I committed I'd
be successful it's actually not true you
can be a thousand percent committed to
something and you can still fail I got
bad news for you that's the reality you
know that's the reality of do you think
the people that BlackBerry weren't
committed to their game you know what I
mean you know but what happened a
blackberry mmm it's it's they were they
were committed but they made some bad
decisions guess what now BlackBerry's
not really in
game anymore well they I think they
changed games I'm not a hundred percent
sure but people think that that because
you didn't quit your job and go all in
and put all your chips on the table that
you're not committed and I actually
don't agree with that and I'll get
here's my example if okay I think that
commitment is actually harder to do when
it's a long-term commitment that you're
going okay you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna stay at my job but I'm gonna work
three hours a day on this other thing
I'm gonna be manufacturing I may be
making my widgets three hours a day when
I get home at ten o'clock at night I'm
gonna go until one o'clock in the
morning making my widgets that's
commitment
mmm-hmm it's actually smart commitment
it actually in some ways takes more
commitment to do that than it does just
to quit your job and say I'm all-in
because now you're holding your
balancing all these different things
you're Carrie you're shouldering more of
a burden so that actually takes more
commitment the problem is that people
they get weak and after the fourth night
of making widgets at 10 o'clock at night
they go yeah I'm notes um it's cool I'll
have a job I have a job
and so that's week I you know an example
be what if you could get in excellent
physical condition in three hours but it
was just like the hardest three hours
that you could imagine think about that
and your body would transform from
whatever crap condition you're in right
now into a specimen and it's gonna take
three hours of just hell how many more
people would be an amazing condition I
think a ton more because committing for
three hours to something even it was
gonna be super bad people would be able
to do it what takes more commitment and
the reason everyone's not walking around
like a perfect specimen is because it
doesn't take three hours it doesn't take
three weeks
it doesn't take three months it takes a
daily grind that goes on for years that
you have to hold the line on on the way
you eat on the way you exercise on your
life and
that takes real commitment yes so it
isn't a lack of commitment it's planning
it isn't a lack of commitment it is
mitigating risk and don't confuse again
I I think that the person that commits
to something and still maintains this
other income stream for example that
person is at least as committed if not
more committed than the person says you
know what screw it I'm going all-in over
here I'm forgetting about you know
quitting my job that's not a smart move
yeah and it takes more that's actually
easier well that's my point it's easier
in many ways to go you know what I'm
quitting this day job I'm quitting my
nine-to-five I'm sick of that cubicle
I'm sick of that construction site I'm
just going all-in over here that is an
easier move that takes less commitment
than saying I'm gonna shoulder the
burden of working 15 18 20 hours a day
for the next two years until I can get
this thing stood up enough to where I
can execute it yeah yes it's almost like
people are conflating the commitment you
know it's like they almost people want
to want to want to do a big show of
commitment by quitting their job but
it's more of just a show of commitment
to show you're committed or you're not
kind of thing yeah and then so a lot of
times with these big shows of commitment
becomes just an immense amount of
stupidity you know yeah meanwhile you
can either come in or don't commit you
know yeah sure if you don't quit your
job and you make widgets and you don't
commit sure it's like all right you got
you can facilitate your non commitment
yeah yeah I dig your your real job your
nine-to-five job is an enabler to you
not committing yeah fully yeah but by no
means is that you don't know poor oaf
yeah yeah and it's important to note
that don't confuse and this is another
mistake so people make mistakes on
either ends of the spectrum the other
one is don't confuse planning and
mitigating risk with not taking action
because that can happen too you have to
make things happen every single day
that's what you have to do if you don't
take action if you don't move which is
what this guy's asking about then yeah
you're paralyzed and you're never gonna
get anywhere but all you have to
chip away if that thing you got to make
a little bit of movement every day yeah
you want to write a book and this is
something I'm familiar with the house
I'm writing books I'm writing another
book right now
hell yeah and you know what I got to do
I got to chip away at that thing every
day every day
yeah every day there's your commitment
words a day 45 minutes maybe an hour
that's what it takes and guess what if I
can't get that hour for whatever reason
guess what I'm gonna get to 20 minutes
I'm gonna get 30 minutes I'm gonna get
something to get in there I'm gonna do
work mmm because I'm gonna be close to
my goal than I was yeah that's the way
it is I think you can see that live
didn't you yes it was my honor that's
but that's where it happens where else
is going to happen right yeah we were
flying back from Maine where I was you
know that goes cruising good yeah I
think I fell asleep couple times yeah
you know but I was hammering I was I was
doing what I have to do mm-hmm because
if I don't do it then when's that what
I'm gonna get that hour that was I was
four hours I had right there yeah it's
late technically 5:00 yeah couldn't get
my computer out for the first a little
bit oh yeah they don't let you so
whatever
oh good yeah I was kind of at times
though speaking over your shoulder like
reading oh let's talk over here
then I see how was it I saw the name
Kenny Williamson in there oh yeah yeah
this good man being composed yeah I
think that all that sounds like kind of
obvious you know when you're saying it
I'm like yeah okay yeah yeah yeah got it
yeah or you know or at least the part
where it's like it's a daily thing like
you got a baby to have a progress you
know like you got to take that step you
know do it um sounds obvious but men how
many times I know this like my friends
and you know whatever oh you go on I
don't know online or whatever and you
see people complaining about you know
stuff never happens for me you know FML
you know FML means yes stuff never
happens to you that's right and stuff
never happens for you that's right yeah
that is life doesn't happen for you in
life you got to go and make it you know
I've explained to my kids you want to
make money you have to
take that money from someone else you
have to take it from them then people
are just gonna walk up and give you
money Yeah right that doesn't happen
that's never happened to me in my life
no one has ever walked up and given me
money you gotta take that money they
gotta give it to you that you got to
make them you got to take it from them
yeah they want that money too mm-hm so
what are you gonna give them that's
gonna make allow you to take it from
them yeah that that's oh yeah guess what
nothing's nothing happens for you that's
right nothing does happen for you you
have to make it happen yeah that's the
default aggressive mindset that you're
gonna make things happen not gonna sit
around and wait for things to happen
it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen oh well guess what I read a story
about this such-and-such a person and
they just walked into this you know
agency and they they thought they looked
did a really good job and now they're
famous okay that's great base your life
on that percentage chance of happening
it's not happening yeah I actually I
actually look at that and just think the
might the chance of anything like that
happened to me are zero nothing good is
gonna happen to me like that that I'm
just gonna get a good deal like that's
not happening zero yeah
so if you're gonna get it you're gonna
have to make it happen yeah next
question yes and that should be the red
flag right there then all right
basically for the for someone who's like
nothing you know when am I gonna get my
big break or or you know nothing happens
for me kind of thing that should be the
red flag right one it's like yeah yeah
you're talking about the fact that
you're not that things aren't coming to
you yeah yeah yeah that should be a real
big red flag nothing is gonna come to
you not happening not happening you got
to go and make things happen and once
you have that attitude I'll tell you
what it's a game-changer yeah it's a
game-changer once you realize that that
book that's so good that's in your head
is not gonna write itself yeah once you
realize that widget that you have this
plan for isn't gonna build itself then
you'll realize like okay I'm gonna have
to make these things happen and even
then guess what you can make a widget
that no one wants to buy and you can
write a book that no one wants to no one
wants to read and if you're not okay
with that which is another thing that
happens people say well you know no one
will like it okay well if that's what
you think well then don't even write it
unless you want to write it for
yourself yeah then write it for yourself
and cool B be proud be stoked be happy
yeah it's interesting to let's say a
book book alright for example it this
kind of reminds me of where you know how
let's say I don't know me let's say oh
I'm I'm a pretty good writer in fact I
even wrote a book before whatever and
then my friend on in Stara face well
whatever someone my neighbor or whatever
they write a book and they they release
it and then they write another one and
mate let's say it's not even really that
good but it's out there they're like
look at my new book and you know they
got people support oh that's awesome you
wrote a book and I mean while I'm like
kind of sour grapes a little bit I'm
like sure I'm a better writer than in
that person meanwhile I didn't write
anymore I'm over here you roll one yeah
yeah I wrote back in the day long time
ago you know but you know I'm saying I'm
in that arena you know and I'm kind of
in my mind hating on this there's people
that hate on them that never even wrote
a book in the first place
yeah no man I'm a better writer I'm a
better film guy I'm a better writer I'm
a better fighter whatever there's all
kinds of people doing that all kinds of
people that that will just be saying I I
was a better whatever fighter jiu-jitsu
player carpenter whatever you name it
yeah meanwhile taking no action software
engineer I could have done that why
didn't you yeah right I'll tell you why
because you weren't committed yes and
the commitment that we're talking about
is it night yeah night
that's what tension or earlier or in the
middle of day whatever you know it how
you said like you're you're not doing
these enormous shows of commitment like
either you're committed or you're not if
you're committed it's gonna show itself
like a question you know all those
people again back to the guy who's like
hating on his neighbor doing
quote-unquote mediocre work like oh
that's John that's not that good hit on
it you know what it's this just made me
think of this sometimes you'd meet a guy
that was say I'm going to SEAL training
and and they kind of be brag about it
and you could see in their eyes
that that right there
was good enough for them Oh like I'm
going to see SEAL team training yeah you
know no one calls the SEAL team training
but that's the kind of person because
they just want to and you I died here
got you you know guys saying that yeah
I'm going to SEAL training the guys that
generally have a better chance or guys
that you know you say oh what are you
doing in the Navy and they say oh you
know I'm um you know just got done with
a school and I'm starting hoping to go
to SEAL training you know you have to
pry it out of them yeah that guy's a
better chance the guy that's already
bragging yeah basically indirectly
bragging because he's implying that he's
gonna make it
those guys gonna have a little bit more
of a rough time now this doesn't mean
they're not this doesn't mean don't be
confident yeah but that's what I'm
saying is some people that are like I'm
going for it they're happy with just
saying I'm committed that quit my job
and this we're gonna do they're happy to
let everyone know that yeah but what
they're not happy to do is grind that's
what they're not happy to do and that's
where that's where you that's where you
make your money right or where you make
your goods or where you become
successful
yeah there's losing somebody and they
were talking about like commit like
people have goals I want to be a singer
or whatever I want to be a CEO and I
want to be a CEO oh you can form up in a
hell L see today and you can become the
CEO exactly right so that's kind of
writers that's part of the point right
there it's like okay you want to be CEO
because you see all this cool stuff on
wherever about being a CEO but really
what you're pursuing isn't necessarily
being this it is but what you're
pursuing where you're gonna end up and
where you're gonna find success as a CEO
if you're pursuing the day-to-day of
being a CEO it's like I said this before
and it's it's on the surface it's lame
but it's it's actually really accurate
like if you want to be a gangster you
have to do gangster stuff every day it's
not just like posing with your guns it's
like you gotta kind of you gotta put in
that work kind of thing you know so if
you're gonna be like you can't just be
Jaco and start a podcast into
in in you know put out a book and that's
it and start collecting money it's not
like that you gotta you gotta go you
know however old you are many years
there's other steps involved later and I
used to joke about you know cuz when we
started a salon front obviously which is
me and him and we'd see some other guy
out there to be a CEO of something and
in we'd be saying well that guy's a CEO
and you look at their company and the
company has them the only one person or
three people right it bro yeah on the
CEO a on the CEO of choco podcast yeah
no it's just you and me there's no CEO
going on here yeah we're cruising too
hard yeah yeah yeah that you gotta focus
on the right things as opposed to the
wrong thing jack next wish chuckle I
coach high school football what should I
do with the star athlete who segregates
himself and won't participate in hard
drills or it won't participate hard in
drills yeah now this one I actually
thankfully remembered that I said I
would do this well because when I got
this this is a Twitter question and I
responded to this Twitter question in
one word so you know he says I got this
guy star athlete won't participate in
drills what should I do with him I
responded in one word bench so so of
course you know then people start saying
well you know it's and and I was like
yeah I know we're on Twitter right we're
on Twitter there's more to it then
what's happening I just answered 798
questions that this was 799 so not gonna
go into full detail but then as people
were kind of chiming it's like okay I'll
answer this on the podcast so we can go
into it a little bit more because yes
your coach your leader and obviously I
talk about this all the time
leadership is a nuanced thing it takes
balance it takes maneuvering it takes
chess playing it takes mental
who takes all those things right so the
obvious answer of just like bench
that's my meathead answer and
fundamentally we'll get to it mm-hmm
but and fundamentally that may be the
result but let's dive into it a little
bit but who's the kid what's his deal
what's his background what's his
attitude where is he coming from
what's his family like life or what's
his family life like what is what's his
past performance what's his record what
year is he in school but there's all
kinds of things we need to know right so
now once we've sort of figured out what
do you like now that any one of those
things any one of those variables is
gonna is gonna change our course of
action a little bit because being a
leader doesn't mean you get to follow
cookie cutter results or of cookie
cutter solutions to things right you're
dealing with human beings and every
single human being is different and
every single human being has a little
craziness to him that you cannot predict
so we're dealing with a kid guess what a
16 year old boy that kid is even more
unpredictable and even more crazy than
most right because he's got testosterone
flowing through his system he's chasing
girls he's he's just going crazy he's
not secure himself yet he's got zits on
his face he's you know he's got gyms
going on he's got issues yeah and so
this kids crazy and we're trying to deal
with him now most kids can get you know
they get through that and they're still
participating the team this kids not so
one of the first things I always say
this you got somebody that's not
stepping up in the leadership position
or they're not wanting you put them in
charge of it hmm you know you say hey
echo I want you to run this drill I
think the way I'm watching you perform
on the field but I think you could
really lead this drill well I want you
to lead this drill to show these guys
what's up right oh so you don't mean
fired up face on you look just there
yeah so that might take his attitude and
now instead of me saying hey echo you
got to do this drill like everyone else
I already know that you don't want to do
that so I'm elevating you a little bit
your ego a little push a little massage
and maybe you feel good about that now
and I say hey you know you can run this
drill faster than anyone else I want you
to lead it I want you show them how to
do it I want you to make our team better
you're gonna fire it up so that's that's
one solution type right I'm just gonna
kind of a broad solution type some other
solution type is is and this is real
easy real easy is when you're talking to
someone that you want to improve their
performance you don't go to them and say
hey you need to get better because
you're just right now you're letting the
whole team down
and you're just you think you're all
good you think you're so good that you
don't need to coach you don't need to
run drills with the team you need to run
drills the team now your attitude is
what are you talking about so instead of
saying that I again I'm gonna ego you up
a little bit be say hey man I'm gonna
talk to you I gotta talk to you because
I see so much potential with you with
your game I see your athletic ability
and I see the way that the other guys on
the team look at you you might not sense
it they look up to you your leader
whether you want to be a leader or not
and the potential that you havin is as
an athlete is not going to come to
fruition unless you at least get some of
your potential as a leader in line so
the reason I want you to run these
drills isn't to make you better I
already know you're good I already know
you're good at the journals the reason I
wants you to run these drills okay I
want you to be even better I want you to
reach your potential and by the way you
helped and run these drills is gonna
make the team better and the better the
team does the better you're gonna do
though more Scouts were gonna here
looking at you so there's that and
obviously I'm gonna explain to him why
the drills are important for him and for
the team and for him and the team
together for the everyone to reach their
potential so those were those are good
too
and I guess overall broadly would I be
doing this whole time is talking to the
person talking to the individual trying
to figure out what his reasons were for
not wanting to participate the drills
and then countering those reasons with
logical answers hmm and you know saying
hey here's why it's important and
explaining it to him and then eventually
you're gonna get to a point where my
coaching my explaining my maneuvering my
mental jujitsu none of its worked and he
still telling me I'm not running the
drills I don't need to cool bench next
question I mean well you played ball
what do you think yeah cuz I didn't play
football yeah no that's exactly right I
would I would think and I'm trying to
put myself in the mindset back when I
was in high school I remember going into
my senior year so you have oh it's kind
of summer training like high school
summer training days no no no that was
that was for fall okay um and that was
like a camp situation but no summer
training which was like after spring and
stuff in it and what they call it they
call it technique sessions and all it
was was like you know I played in high
school was kind of like a slap back
which is a hybrid running back wide
receiver tight and so the technique
sessions were just kind of passing
drills and you know just hand stuff and
maybe even some footwork but it was kind
of fun it was just you know the
quarterback goes there and the receivers
in the right beckylyn you catch passes
run routes and stuff and you know for
like I don't know 45 minutes hour and so
I remember going to my senior year in
there talking about yeah technique
sessions this year whatever whatever and
I remember I was just talking to Jake my
brother and I was like yeah I technique
sessions it's the kind where if you
don't go you don't get in big trouble or
nothing it's just strongly encouraged
you know that kind of see okay I'm not
going to those kind of because I was
real I had done you were the man I'd
done well as a junior and I knew that
now as a senior I'm really gonna do well
whatever whatever that's that was my
little thought I don't need to go to
those like yeah I'm not going into those
with this kind of tone that like that's
for people who are trying to trying to
get better me I'm already kind of thing
you know
and Jake goes he goes oh yeah like we're
super sarcastic like almost offended he
was like oh yeah cuz you don't need that
huh and he's and then he said yeah cuz
you're just so much better than everyone
else actually I think that both of those
and I was like bro it hit me really hard
even if even if like even if I really
believed which it's dumb to believe that
I won't benefit from that training even
if it's like I'm just like yeah I'm
better than you my whole team by the way
yeah the team sport we all work together
to win this stuff
oh you guys I'm better than all you guys
yeah yeah that's it that's the feeling
and he hit me real hard I mean I didn't
miss any of them committed so there was
that so in that in that mindset right
going in because that's probably what it
is that might be just that and it makes
sense like we're in your mind if you
don't get it brought to your attention
like that's really what it is I don't
need to do these drills I'm scoring
touchdowns every single game why am i
doing these drills that all these nons
touchdown scoring people are doing you
know yeah just put me in when it's time
to score touch that kind of an attitude
you know that's probably what it is
or making tackles or whatever the
position is I don't know so just like
how you said make him kind of in charge
of it mmm like this guy I don't know
let's his name's Jim I don't know um Jim
you know take these guys and show him
how it's done kind of thing in practice
cuz if you say I'm not gonna go this
thing the coach came up and said hey
echo are you you missed two practices
and you're like yeah you know and he was
like hey man I need you to set the
example and really show these guys how
it's done and you're not even showing up
yeah
even in me what me back in those days if
if you would have left out that like you
didn't show up part leave that part out
that would have compelled me way more
like if you're like you man you're as a
junior killing it and now it's about to
be your senior year you guys how it's
done oh yeah you know because it's like
feeding the kind of thing and boom out
oh yeah big time she take charge in um
Pop Warner football which is you know
younger guys in when I played for the
Koloa Rams yeah sound ruthless they are
still are by the way and so my coach's
name is coach Scoville and he had this
kind of its kind of like a policy kind
of a thing where when you do jumping
jacks when you do you know drills like
they come crash drills it's just like oh
you do this stuff you roll you do these
things and while you do this in practice
and even before the game when you're
warming up you yell as loud as you can
that's it you yell little kids just
yelling getting that for his reasons and
it worked man we're good and so
what I would do is I would try to be the
like yell as loud as I possibly can to
be the loudest guy during the entire
whatever you're doing you're just
yelling the entire time the drills yeah
when it's your turn not not if you're
standing you know stand up in line god
and then the guys go yeah so the coach
stands in front of three guys three
lines and the guys in the front are
doing the drills so he holds the ball
and you go and you just basically
shuffle your feet and he goes like that
then you turn then you come back and
goes this way turn and then he goes down
then you basically sprawl you know boom
stand back huh you know and then he goes
okay like that and then the three guys
run now it's the next guy's driver you
see I'm saying so and when you're
running you gotta yell to so I that's
really good cardiovascular work yeah to
be yelling because you can't breathe as
much what it does is gets you in the
habit of just going hard hard every play
you know and when you're done you don't
have to yell you're cruising you're
resting getting right and when one is go
time is go time and habitually that's
how it was man it was it really worked
and so anyway when I would yell as I and
the coach would do this to a lot of kids
when you yell super loud you know you
can just see here that guy yelling above
everybody who'd give that guy attention
look at this guy he's getting out yeah
look at this guy and now the next guy
he's gonna try to out yell that guy go
harder go harder so it's that same idea
you know you give that guy props for
working hard or showing everybody how
it's done kind of thing and it's like
man who's gonna keep that shit up and
everyone's gonna want it in fact Jeff
did me like that this week in training
so I go in and just like okay after
training is like everybody you know ever
loved her yeah he um you know you do
some push-ups right he'll make you do
some push-ups or whatever and um he's
like okay do the triangle drill you know
when you're on your back you rock back
you do Randall you rock back again go
the other side so you know all levels
are in there beginners as well and so
I'm doing it it goes all everybody in
the middle of egos stop watch out echo
does it and I'm like if I didn't see
what was going on here I would feel
really empowered to try for now and in
you know so he successfully pulled that
off as far as the feeling in my head to
a grown adult that know cuz you and were
you doing them yeah I was doing it with
everybody when he pauses the whole class
and said watch how he does it you know
so this exact same concept up your
a little bit yeah techniques shown
everybody yeah yeah no it's good man
that works then like a and the point
there is even if you know that that's
what they're doing to you it's still
yeah hey if you were the type of coach
that had already had this happened
before and like you just benched guy he
and the coach had the reputation that
you don't play around this wouldn't have
happened in the first place really would
it yeah so you you may have to set the
example at some point yeah the only
drawback of that potentially is you
could because in high school a lot of
the times like you can have one or two
guys on the team sometimes even one guy
on the team that will dictate the
outcome of the game where if this guy's
playing there you'll you'll probably win
if he's not you'll probably lose and you
have those dynamics in high school um so
if you run that risk where I mean unless
you if you're looking at a bigger
picture like well I guess this is a bad
example if the guy if you if you as a
coach run things in a certain way yeah
well you have well you don't allow any
slack yeah then the probability of this
occurring is gonna be less yeah it can
be done for sure like you know it's it's
a funny story life tells sometimes is we
were doing desert training and long
story short there's a opportunity to
have guys take a break and go to town
and have some beer and get a good meal
before the field training exercises
start and that's normal what everyone
does but we didn't do that we didn't
take a break didn't go get food didn't
go get beers nothing we just got after
him more and I didn't really think much
of it but life was like yeah of course
we wanted to go but no no one wanted to
ask you yeah because it was just like
yeah no slack what went on obviously
we're not we're out here to train and
get something we're not here to you know
go into town and drink a beer no and
it's kind of funny looking back but I
think that that you can establish
yourself as a type of leader that just
not gonna allow like what are you
talking about you don't want to do the
drills oh but it starts with the little
things like who knows what this this kid
you know maybe he didn't want to put on
his practice jersey any wonder where
this you know what I mean just little
things little things build up and
eventually he seemed just like a normal
kid just like a five-year-old that
pushes the envelope
everything oh yeah oh maybe we're gonna
get away can't get aware that what can I
get away mmm
people like to push the envelope around
my life ya know slot I know yeah but you
can go too far with no slack of course
yeah and you now now it rotates you as a
coat yeah cuz you just don't understand
you don't listen and you're a jerk yeah
you've you've gone too far in one
direction or you've gone too far in the
other direction balance dichotomy a
leadership get some yeah next question
chuckle have you ever had a person you
couldn't get through to something that
you couldn't manipulate then what what
do you do when you can't get through
well yeah of course I've had people that
I could not get through to and generally
speaking these people are like level 12
arrogance that's what they are giant ego
that's what causes this there was quite
a few seal leaders that I dealt with I
shouldn't say quite a few there was
several seal leaders that I dealt with
that would like that and of several
business leaders that I've dealt with
that I were like that in podcast number
five I read that counselling letter
mm-hm
corrective measures to a guy that was
really arrogant and despite that letter
he did not change and he got fired so
what do you do when you got someone that
you can't get through to you you fire
them that's what if they're if and
here's what you got to do is what what
makes that tricky is that some people
and this may this this make people
freaked out there are some people that
they're such good performers that even
though they're slightly negative on
maybe their team participation but
they're so good that that it offsets
their negativity right and that happens
it happens you know what happens with
sales people sales people are are in
order to be in a sales position you
gotta be confident you got to be
aggressive you got to be somewhat
arrogant right you got to believe in
yourself and so some salespeople take
that to the extreme where they're just
like I don't need to listen to what
you're telling me the new procedures are
yeah screw that I'm the one that's doing
the big dollars over here how much you
follow my procedures boys
right so that happens you well then what
you got to do is you got to look does is
this guy producing so well now that can
create problems within the team mmm and
you have to balance those things it is
this guy is the negative it is creating
offset by the awesome productivity
videos do it and furthermore if the guy
is that good hey maybe we should be
modeling some things after them I have
no problem with that if you're the best
performer cool I want to imitate you I
want to get my people to imitate you so
that happens at the other place where
you might see it a similar situation is
a leader that does really good with
their relationships down the chain of
command for instance but it really has
bad relations up the chain of command so
again you got to ask yourself okay if I
fire this leader how many these people
that he has great relationships are now
going to leave and what kind of
detriment is that to the team that can
also happen with someone that doesn't
that treats their people like crap but
up the chain of command everyone thinks
he's great and and he's getting the
mission done by the way mmm right he's a
slave driver and he's creating total
animosity between him and his team but
he's accomplishing the mission so now
how would he do there's a risk everyone
could quit there's risk you could
fireman now you don't accomplish the
mission anymore this is why leadership
is hard and this is why you have to
balance everything mm-hmm you have to
balance those things but talked about it
a bunch of times if you get someone you
coach them you mentor them you do
everything you can you flank them you do
jujitsu
mental jujitsu on them you try and get
them squared away and eventually if you
can't you weigh against you know how
it's going to affect the situation and
then in many cases you got to let him go
and we fired you know we fired five saw
plenty of seals get fired from
leadership positions and and same thing
with you know obviously we work with
consulting businesses we see all kinds
of people getting fired because they're
either not capable of doing their job
they're too arrogant and they don't
recognize that things are going sideways
and they're just thinking that they're
doing everything perfect no that's not
gonna work out well for you hmm
you know what did I think his life said
Oh
someone asked him you know when do you
know when's that line where it's like
when it's time to fire someone yeah and
he was like in a nutshell there's a lot
to it but in a nutshell which that was
dope
he said it's you know you're at that
point where you fire someone when when
you don't feel bad about it right right
so it's like yeah you you tried every
tried everything and and there's also
people boots there's some validity to
this that say the first time you think
you should fire someone you should fire
that's the other end of the spectrum
right and what that means is when you're
looking at someone and you're going man
okay I can save them I can help that's
the kind of advice you give to someone
that's that's a that's got a maternal
instinct right that you meet someone hey
I know this guy's just a good guy and
everyone my team is great and everyone's
gonna do great job you can't tell that
person what life and I normally tell
people which is when you feel good about
it you should fire him because that
person will never feel good about firing
anybody just okay I'm saying because I
decide to duska I know he's gonna make
it no he's gonna come around you know I
and then they then they start playing
the the extreme ownership game which is
you know if I would have given echo a
better direction he would have been able
to do this it's my fault I have a given
echo 17 iterations of this and he still
didn't complete it correctly he's fired
that's the way it works right there's
yeah so balanced so that spectrum of of
you know being within the confines of
being justified firing somebody a
certain type of person you gotta say
when you don't feel bad about it right
right
I mean that's like a fire heavy type
dude right but there's also someone the
reason you shouldn't feel bad about it
is because I've done everything I can do
to help you yeah which takes work it
takes effort it takes tact
it takes hard conversations because it's
hard for me to go and say echo you know
I've been I've been looking at your
videos lately and they're they're not
really what we're looking for right and
I don't want to say that to you you know
it's uncomfortable and we're kind of
like you know we we want to get along so
instead I'm like yeah echo that that
video is good man yeah it's good but I'm
not telling you
and then over time our videos are
looking good enough and eventually I say
you know what
you know we're no one's buying our
videos anymore and we haven't gotten any
new contracts so guess what I'm gonna
have to let you go you're about you said
all the videos I made were good now
you're firing me
maybe you need to become a better
salesperson yeah
whereas if I had the hard conversation
early and said hey echo you know I know
you're creative and I appreciate that
but we also need to get the message
across for our clients I'm obviously
fabricating a business where we're
making videos of hidden money for
clients which I know we don't really do
a lot of anymore occasionally you do but
yeah you got to you got to have the hard
conversations earlier if I'm the type of
person that doesn't like to have the
hard conversations
once again I never feel good about it
cuz I never I never gave you any advice
so it always feels bad for me to fire
someone yeah but if you're following
good leadership tactics then absolutely
true when you get to a point where
you've got to fire somebody you won't
feel bad about it because you know
you've done everything you can you know
you've coach that mentor them and you
know that if you keep them on board you
are negatively impacting your team which
is bad yeah and then go down to the
other side of the spectrum still within
the confines of being justified in
firing somebody by the way but on the
other side of the spectrum you get how
you say that what do you call the
maternal instinct time to respect the
person who can like there they're just
super hard on themself maybe or they're
you know like even if you did do
everything you can you still like I
could've done more
you know so it's my fault that is I feel
like I let them down as a leader yeah
they've them 17 counseling chits yeah
you know they don't belong here you
can't do their job stop yeah I mean well
they're going home laughing at you or
whatever yeah yeah you get that kind of
personality so it's kind of like how you
say you gotta balance it you got to be
like okay you gotta recognize okay what
kind of person am i you know or what
kind of person is this other person kind
of thing and if they're those maternal
instinct jewel for lack of a better way
putting a person then what was it the
first time you feel like you should fire
them you should fire you you hang out on
that side of the spectrum you got honest
how do you regain respect from your
employees after you have come across as
too nice my husband and I are business
owners with 45 employees in a small
software firm since adding more
employees in the last 18 months the
culture is changing I blame our
easygoing attitude increasingly there is
an attitude problem where negative
pushback has become almost a daily
occurrence how do we lead our way out of
this okay well this is a rough one not
by no means I shouldn't have even said
it's a rough one it's a challenge right
you have to hit the reset button for
sure and you got to let people know that
things are changing now I would straight
up have a meeting that you you sit
everyone down and say hey here's what's
happening we are growing and as we grow
we are going to have to evolve just like
a person as you get older you have to
evolve you have to become more mature
and here's some of the things that we're
gonna have to tighten up right is
instead of you know everyone's just hey
if you come in and you want to go you
gotta you know it's your kids birthday
oh you have no problem day off you say
look that's not happening anymore we
will do our best to let you out for your
daughter's birthday we will do our best
to let you go take care of family
members when they're sick we will do our
best to give you bonuses that you've
become accustomed to we will do our best
to give you raises annually we will do
our best to continue to take care of you
but none of those things are guaranteed
at all we are trying to be profitable in
fact we have to be profitable in order
to continue as a business on top of
being profitable in order to grow we
have to reinvest in the company we have
to take the money that we make and we
have to put it back into the
company in order to grow and we are
going to grow that is our goal and in
order to grow we are going to have to
put procedures and standards in place
now that will allow us to maintain some
control and efficiency as we grow if we
don't do that we're gonna fall apart so
that is what we need to do now why do we
want to grow the reason we want to grow
is because we want to be bigger we want
to create more opportunity for everyone
sitting in this room we're not trying to
grow for us we're trying to grow for
everyone the more opportunity everyone
has to advance and leadership to make
more money that is what we are trying to
do but we can only do that if we as we
grow we evolve and become better and
become more efficient and become more
standardized in the next 18 to 24 months
that is what we have to do as a company
so I would have a meeting and say
something like that something along
those lines
lay down the law a little bit now also
then you have to change your attitude
you have to somewhat change your
attitude because you are mr. nice guy
that's how you ended up in this position
you you know the husband-and-wife team
mr. mr. and mrs. nice guy mm-hmm and you
can and should be nice as a leader I
understand that but at this point the
team needs to get tightened up and so
you're gonna have to impose some
discipline on them in order for there to
be freedom in the future surprisingly
right but we know that now I had a
friend who was a platoon commander and
he was he worked with me and I knew him
and when he was a platoon commander he
was a real nice guy super nice guy when
he was a platoon commander he was a nice
guy super nice guy things didn't work
out good for him because I don't know
that I don't I don't specifically know
what happened but I know that things
didn't go great and when he talked to me
about it
because the thing is when I worked with
him we were all Bros and I was young
enlisted
but we know we were all bros but we all
had that level of respect hey you know
what we can go out and have a beer
tonight but tomorrow morning we get to
work I'm in the game and I'm you know
I'm I'm telling the line and that's
pretty much what we were all like all of
us unless the guys working with this guy
and when he got to this new place
Newcombe and all of a sudden wasn't like
that anymore and he was broening out
with people and when he get back into
work they wanted to bro out at work and
it was like well we don't need to listen
to you we were having beers with you
last night and that's what he told me he
said you know I was too nice of a guy
and I didn't get the respect that I
needed to be able to effectively run the
platoon mm-hmm and it was not good and
he said something to me too which I I
guess I instinctively knew or maybe I
didn't but it stuck with me you know
it's real easy to give more slack to
someone when you have them on a tight
leash right it's real easy yeah yeah
it's hard to do the other thing it's
hard to well listen to this when I have
you on a tight leash and I give you a
little slack you're happy you're like oh
look at chocolate rust me he's letting
me go a little bit yeah when I give you
all kinds of got all kinds of slack and
all of a sudden I have to tighten up I
start pulling on the leash well guess
what it chokes your neck it chokes you
and I started bringing in them and the
further I got to pull you back on in the
longer you're choking for yeah and so by
the time you get back to me you're ready
to bite yeah and so that's what you have
to do you don't walk in and put the dogs
out and let them run wild on to the end
of the leash and let them run whatever
they want and then try and pull them
back in because when you let him go by
the way you're thinking yourself well
you know this is a good dog so when I
let him run around he's not gonna do
anything wrong he's gonna be a perfect
saint when there's a chance that that's
gonna happen and there's a chance that's
a good dog and you let him run around
and when you say come back he comes back
to you there's also a chance that he's
not a good dog and when he gets out
there he starts running and started
biting people or
running in the road or doing whatever
bad dogs do and so what do you have to
do that dogs you got to pull them back
to you
and it's it's actually worse because we
already know this is a bad dog so now
when you pull him back he's pissed and
he's gonna bite you
whereas a good dog wasn't doing anything
bad the first place and when you pull
him back and he looks at you and goes
hey I must have gone to out of control
I'm sorry
I'm back in line now you seen him saying
there's a the the way the whole thing
unfolds is bad because the bad dog he's
a bad dog and he's doing bad stuff when
you give him slack on the leash and when
you're pulling back he's gonna snap at
you
mmm the good dog you give him all kinds
of room on me she's not do anything good
and when you pull him back he goes he
goes oh sorry I didn't realize I was
doing something outlined master sure
I'll keep it in check now and you can
give me more slack if you want or not
doesn't matter I want to I want you to
trust me
meanwhile the bad dog he's just like
growling yeah he's pissed so that's
gonna be a hard one like I said it's not
impossible but the big thing you got to
do I think in this situation you got to
be clear here's what's going on
you could even potentially I don't know
how well you are of a speaker
interacting with people you could even
say something along the lines of you
know hey look we've been running this
real loose and I've been real you know
we've been doing everything we could to
run this as loose as possible but we
gotta tighten it up I think that's I
think you could say that because you
don't say look I've been being nice and
I can't be nice anymore that that comes
across wrong but I say look we've been
running it real loose here and we've
been trying to give you guys as much
freedom as we can and we still want you
guys to have freedom but we got to put
some parameters in place that are gonna
that are gonna allow us to run this
business efficiently as we grow and as
we scale you can quote me on that one
but yeah make sense when you see them be
clear and consistent you know like how
um you know some people they'll
implement rules and I'm speaking from an
employee standpoint where I'm looking at
the boss when they're trying to put in
new rules to tighten it up so to speak
is in the nightclub industry that tends
to happen
you know managers browing out with I
like to turn bro out but you never I
don't think so not that I remember
but it's interesting I thought that was
pretty common vernacular especially
amongst a bro like yourself yeah bro you
know though um yeah and the nightclub
managers tend to bro out with people or
you know bro out with girls or whatever
the waitresses whatever whatever I don't
know if you can bro out with the girls
probably a different word for a group of
words whatever but nonetheless that
tends to happen so soon you know some
Ness a same situation you know you get
nightclubs in this disarray as a
business you know then they gotta
tighten it up and apply more rules and
now you got a you know whatever with the
clock ins it's like just little rules
yeah yeah I'm a late person to the whole
clock-in thing anyway long story but uh
so when the manager would implement the
rules but they don't follow the rules
you know it's man it they just won't
take and people get more mad but when
you see there is this man and he died -
unfortunately Joel he was um he was he
was our boss for for a while and he he
had to kind of do that like implemented
rules but this was that he would bro out
with you but like it was weird he did
this weird kind of balance where he
would break some rules but then he'd
follow rules but the rules that he broke
he wouldn't care if you broke him kind
of thing these are all small teeny tiny
rules by the way but he was a real
consistent person you know where he
wanted something done we were all doing
it including him you know and I remember
thinking man this I really like this guy
in that way as well where he's telling
us to do stuff but he won't like because
there was other managers all man I could
go into it then where there's all the
other managers and they were straight-up
like I'm the manager here it just could
never one worships me and it's a weird
dynamic at nightclubs anyway
and they wouldn't follow the rules at
all you know but you had to cuz you're
the employee you know kind of thing but
yeah when you're a manager and again
employees standpoint and and I see my
boss following the new rules
consistently yeah it's so much easier to
sign on it's kinda okay that's what
we're doing I dig it and yeah if you
combine it with like what you said being
clear well I'm down I'm down for the
change I get it man really they get it
oh yeah next question
chuckle no bad teams only bad leaders
and always the same relationship with
each boss yet you also staged a mutiny
how do you reconcile them okay so what
he's talking about obviously no bad
teams no bad leaders is from extreme
ownership and it's actually from before
that Napoleon said the same thing
hackworth said the same thing we we
changed the words a little bit but so
that's and then the other thing he's
talking about is that I always say I
have the same relationship with every
boss I've ever had whether they were
stupid or smart or whether they were
aggressive or passive whether they were
big eagle or humble I always had the
same relationship with all of them that
is they trust me and they gave me what I
needed you to do my job so how do i
reconcile but then then he's talking
about the staged a mutiny because we had
a kind of a mutiny in one of my platoon
broken adjourn when I was a young
enlisted guy and so how can you do that
right if I had all these great
relationships with all my bosses and
Lola but I staged a mutiny interesting I
actually had a decent relationship with
a guy that I staged a mutiny with now
that I think about it so to go back to
the earlier question well talking about
being a renegade and you know being a
rebel and and like I said you you have
to rebel when it is necessary so and
also for the mutiny that is in question
I need to make it clear here
I didn't staged the mutiny wasn't me hmm
it was kind of a group effort that was
somewhat led by the leadership of our
the enlisted leadership of our platoon
and it was a movement that I certainly
supported and was on board with and we
were kind of the e5 mafia in that
platoon
sure yeah so we were kind of had the
voice of the people right me and a
certain group of guys actually from my
buds class
who were all kind of yeah kind of just
fired up about things and you know I it
wasn't like the thing is it wasn't like
the platoon commander had a couple
weaknesses right and maybe he wasn't the
best of tactics or maybe it wasn't that
you know he wasn't the best shot or
anything like wasn't the best athlete no
he was a good effort
he tactically he was like marginal but
what he didn't have talked about this
all time what he didn't have has even
have any humility at all and so he
wasn't listening to anyone that was
giving him any input including he had
very experienced senior enlisted
advisors so the platoon chief and the
platoon LPO were awesome guys very
respected SEALs one of them had been in
the first Gulf War on the ground getting
after it as much as he could so these
guys were experienced on the senior
chief was a really really smart guy and
this guy wasn't listening to him and so
you had somebody that in a situation was
it would have been bad for the platoon
to have this type of leader in there and
now think about this if it's bad for the
platoon that it's bad for your mission
mmm if you don't have a good platoon you
can't execute your mission well and
that's the bottom line to this question
that is how I reconcile this how does
this situation affect the mission affect
our ability to accomplish the mission
how does it do it if we have a bad
leader and it makes us a bad platoon
then we're not gonna be able to
accomplish our mission and therefore I
need to help get rid of this person
because my number one thing that I'm
trying to do is be good at my mission
mm-hmm and obviously a more unified team
is going to accomplish the mission more
effectively and more efficiently period
so that you know that is why it is so
important for people to understand the
mission and the goal and the commander's
intent
because all of your decisions are based
on and guided by that understanding of
understanding what the mission is so you
need to put the mission first all the
time to make the right decision now as
soon as I say that what pops in your
head
Oh Jocko you care about the mission more
than you care about your men not true
because think about this if you aren't
executing your mission effectively you
are taking care of your men that's in
the business world and it's in the
battlefield because in the business
world if I'm executing my my mission
effectively guess what we're doing we're
making more money what being more
profitable we're gaining more clients
we're growing and therefore I'm taking
care of my employees because I'm keeping
them employed and making them more
bonuses and making them more money and
offering them more leadership
opportunities in combat same thing if we
are good and I execute my mission
effectively guess what we've mitigated
risk in the best possible way the more
we mitigate risk the more people are
alive the Blessed casualties we take so
if I'm doing everything geared towards
the mission then then I am taking care
of my men because by the way if I'm
running a mission with heavy casualties
or what about my next mission right so
if you're my boss and you tell me to
charge this machine-gun nest with my
guys and I say boss you know we
shouldn't do that right now you do you
carry out the mission okay well who's
gonna do the next mission right there's
not unlimited guys here so you can't do
it you can't run a mission after you've
taken heavy casualties just like you
can't if you as a business person if you
expend all of your capital on one
project well guess what you can't do the
next project so a good job you
accomplish the one mission but you can't
accomplish any more on the battlefield
if you incur a bunch of casualties for
one mission you can't accomplish any
more so in both those cases
the more effectively you you handle the
mission not just the one mission but
your broad mission your strategic
mission the better you do that the
better you are taking care of your men
and the better you're taking care of
your people in the business world so and
on top of that on top of that 99% of the
time your mission is aligned with the
best thing for your people that's what
I'm saying
99% of the time if we make more money as
a company it helps all my people if we
if we accomplish missions in the most
effective and efficient and take the
least casualties that's the best thing
for my people hmm so back to the
question how do i reconcile these things
I look at how I can best accomplish the
mission and if it best accomplish the
mission to rebel against what's
happening there are some cases where I
might not you might be my boss and I
might not like you but you've got a
great relationship with the army
commander and we're working in their
battle space hmm would it make sense for
me to throw a mutiny and get you fired
no it'd make no sense whatsoever it's
gonna be better for our mission if I say
echo sucks but I'm gonna listen to him
and we're in a massage this thing or to
make things work because he has such a
good relationship with this army
commander that he's making things happen
mm-hmm so I might not do it I might not
stage emit a mutiny not based on the
fact that you that your level of sucking
but based on the fact that what's more
important to me is that we accomplish
our mission and if you have a good
relationship with the army commander I'm
gonna keep you around mmm if you were if
you were in a business situation and you
had you were not doing a good job and
you're one of my subordinates you're not
doing a good job
but you have this great relationships
with all these clients and we're
accomplishing our mission well because
you've built these great relationships
am I just gonna fire you because I think
you're doing it figures I think you're a
crappy leader of your men no actually
I'm not what is best for the mission hmm
now I might have Church secondary and
tertiary plans to move you into position
where you don't have to handle the
operational things that you suck at and
I might put you in a position where
you've just going to become
you know a business debt a biz dev guy
well you're out there meeting greeting
people cuz that's what you're good at
I might make that happen but I'm not
just gonna go echoes a bad leader fire
him throw away the the skill that you do
have and now we're not accomplishing our
mission because I ruined all the
relationships because now you go to all
these all these other partners that we
have and you're going to yeah jock will
fired me
he's pathetic he doesn't realize what
we're doing here I'm going over to this
company come with me
bring your business over here with me so
you reconcile it by looking at the
mission and the mission is almost always
aligned with taking care of your people
and taking carrier people in the sense
of imposing discipline or not imposing
discipline it is being disciplined and
making them work and giving them
training them hard pushing them that is
generally what taking care your people
is yeah taking care of your people isn't
hey you know what echo uh you know don't
worry about that video that you owe to
the client I know you I know it's your
daughter's birthday you go ahead and go
home for the day
am I taking care of you if I do that no
am i taking care of you
no I'm not I'm actually hurting you
because now we got a bad reputation we
delivered the video late the company
passes word to the next company and says
hey you know those guys are there video
is okay but it doesn't matter because it
was late mm-hmm now that's the
reputation we have now fast forward six
months we're downsizing I don't need you
anymore I'm gonna make them you know I
don't need for video makers I only need
one and you're not the one use you know
Sam so I'm not taking care of my people
if I focus on the mission which is hey
echo I apologize I know it's your
daughter's birthday but guess what wheel
this video we got to get it done and you
gotta get in here and make it happen am
I taking care of you then yes I am I
know doesn't feel that way but yes I am
yeah
making sure they're equipped capable and
treated fairly yeah yeah I said impose
discipline on them yeah and like that
doesn't work yeah but what you have to
do is you have to impose this point make
sure there's the dichotomy yeah because
you don't want to say echo you will come
in and make this video right I'm
imposing this on your back echo we owe
this video we said we're gonna turn it
in let me tell you the ramifications if
we don't do this here's what's gonna
hurt it's gonna hurt this this this this
and this gonna eventually could end up
with you not having a job and me not
having a business yeah do you like the
sounds of that no you don't know you
might be the wrong guy to ask about this
maybe you're not I don't know but what
do you think
so you mentioned missing your my
daughter's birthday I didn't miss my
birthday by the way oh did you say you
did or did not did not but my son just
had a first birthday I did miss that but
it's his first birthday so I've always
thought this is before I had any kids
with any birthdays that the first
birthday that's for the parents it's
something that you know he doesn't
remember the first yup his first
birthday never yo I'm definitely gonna
be the wrong person so missing birthdays
is that like a bell curve like okay one
first birthday each one you can sort of
miss that h0 you can't really miss that
meaning when they're born go go talk to
the military people right I know I know
yeah no you're right and I'm saying if
you have the options and you know we're
speaking in terms of okay gosh that sure
I mean you sort of have like in terms of
you know we're at this company you're my
boss on the video maker hey echo you
know we gotta get this video done
whatever I don't know that maybe even in
extreme case I'm saying in a general
sense mm-hmm which birthdays are more
expendable that's ultimately the
question and it doesn't necessarily mean
in this yeah specific I'm gonna tell you
right now as a guy that was in the
military for 20 years the birthday if
you're there it's a luxury if you're
there for Christmas it's the luxury yeah
Thanksgiving it's a luxury I missed all
kinds of that stuff all over the place
just like a big joke you big you know
you're just not gonna be there okay so
now mm-hmm
we're not in the military uh-huh no and
it's less about missing okay so at the
end of the day no matter what birthday
even right now you're thinking if you
miss them no huge deal
no I mean and if I actually thought it
was a huge deal I would have to choose
an entirely different lifestyle and life
right right and I'll tell you what my
kids know yeah yeah okay they've always
known okay so yeah what someone's out
there getting after he's named he's
named my dad he missed another birthday
don't care I get you yet no you're did
it and but that's kind of in a way I
mean not to be too specific and
splitters but I'm gonna do it anyway I
mean not even necessarily you interpret
specific situation which are the most
important break exactly right on the
spectrum of values their bodies 5
through 11 5 through 11 are have the
most weight most weight ok so not 0 not
when they're born
nope so you know if you miss you the
birth of your child because you had to
work and I'm not saying military I'm
saying it because you're trying to
finish some report or something
yeah or whatever or say that yeah try me
that's okay so but comparatively
speaking the the birth of your child
compared to the fifth birthday you say
fifth birthday is more important because
they don't remember anything from zero
to four right yeah that's a good point
those parents that you take your kids
and I did this to actually I didn't I
did it with my first kids my wife think
we could take the girls to Disneyland
yeah okay walking around at Disneyland
which is pretty close to a living hell
degree standing in lines in Anaheim
summertime like just baking and and yet
you know here's the deal the girls are
just so excited the whole time and so
happy
me know so now I haven't been to any of
those things in a long time actually I
went with a business group and walked
around we're at Disneyland in Disney
World and I was like you've gotta kill
me now but this is the thing the kids
don't remember it you can show them
pictures and they go oh that's cool you
could stage those pictures Langly and be
like just set them up but you know yeah
Cinderella
whatever you seen before five yeah okay
action man that's a good point because
when I say now I'm sure there's
developmental things happening when
they're when you do things when you
participate in activities with your kids
obviously yeah but you're five yeah but
you know you can you could probably it'd
probably be more developmentally helpful
for you to spend a day with them you
know coaching them and in jiu-jitsu or
coaching them in boxing or coaching them
and muy Thai or coaching them and
shooting or coaching them in archery or
coaching them in hunting small animals
or coaching them and how to do combat
trauma care just like general theta four
euros yeah you're right you're right um
yeah yeah that's as opposed to go to
Disneyland looking yeah the question is
like the birthday thing so so so yeah
only because you mentioned because by
11:00 they don't care anymore by 11:00
they don't care okay that's my kids
we're all like oh my birthday don't care
yeah man that's a good point
we have a rule you get to picture where
you go out for dinner on your birthday
night and in the last like five
birthdays we haven't even been able to
pull that off successfully yeah it's
obvious it's gonna be what what the
group is used to but as far as the kid
it you missing the birthday for you know
for the Queen I was a kid you know what
I used to pick cuz that used to be in my
family too we get to like pick dinner
you know us to pick yeah chicken patties
oh it's just from the store store just
give some chicken patties I used to love
those things
dang yeah I remember in school with the
kalua elementary school I used to love
the chicken patties there yeah they're
dope the chicken patties are you
suddenly Chicken McNugget egg flat
Chicken McNugget yeah and I didn't even
like I didn't like steak until I was in
the day because because we didn't have a
lot of steak growing up cuz steak is
expensive yeah
swishy that really yeah especially that
ribeye so we didn't have steak we had
chicken patties yeah
taste a good to me and really don't and
sometimes you know what else of course
want McDonald's when you're seven sure
and once coats get some fries in a
shamrock shaky we try I had told because
you know I love mint chocolate chip
right so I had told all my kids about
the the original mint chocolate chip
milkshake was the shamrock shake at
McDonald's barking a dirty yeah which
they'd have around st. Patty's Day which
by the way isn't around my birthday but
it just made him in my mind yeah yeah so
so when I was a kid we had shamrock
shakes st. Patty's Day there mint shakes
and when I was a kid they were amazing
and I was so and I hadn't had one in
thirty years
maybe maybe forty years hadn't had a
shamrock shake and I saw a little
advertisement I said all kids guess what
these are like mint chocolate chip
milkshakes but there's no chocolate chip
so it's just smooth mint ice cream
milkshake from McDonald yep and I sent
my daughter out to go get us all go get
us all shamrock shakes mmm brought them
home they were disgusting they were
nothing like what they used to be yeah
so McDonald's I gave you a shot sorry
but yeah
I'm surprised you gave him a shot I am
too but it's been 40 something years
since I had a shamrock shake and I
remember them so I figured we'll go with
it maybe they're disgusting yeah they're
probably no not even my kids like them
not even my 8 year old dang who just you
know is an 8 year old that just looks at
things and say that's ice cream
I don't want it she didn't like it no no
no wonder we are they were discussing we
threw them all away
dang so don't waste your money yeah
don't waste your money yeah don't waste
money on McDonald's that's my personal
recommend yeah period
shamrock shake or otherwise yeah yeah
yeah it's not health not out not helping
you in any way did you know that they
just I mean this is gonna sound obvious
now that I'm saying it out loud they add
the green coloring to it
mmm to the ice cream make it green well
yeah yeah I think so when you get
Breyers it's white yeah I got a
chocolate
I mean my wife and from whatever family
the family goes to or the Oregon coast
that's where the Tillamook cheese
factories wait yeah yeah Tillamook juice
the root the actual big factory and you
can go in little tours and they give you
ice cream like okay I want that mint
mint chip of course and they and they
hand it to me and I'm like the first
time I see it I was like hey that's not
mine that's obviously just the regular
chocolate oh yeah don't over here and I
feel said that I was like oh I ordered
the mint and he goes oh yeah that's mint
and then it all kind of came to me like
oh yeah I'm pretty dumb for if you get
Breyers Breyers is white yeah yeah which
is the preferred brand to be quite
honest with you no is it okay all right
well at least at least the ones that
I've tried yeah so so back to the
birthday thing if you miss you the birth
of your child technically you're right
technically for the question because I'm
talking about like how upset or how much
it's not affected yeah at all really but
here's the thing it like as a cohesive
family that might be a thing if you have
the option I'm saying if you're overseas
that's legit you know but if you have
the choice so you missed the birth of
your child that's more of like a family
thing like okay but that's not one
that's not the question
because so it's the first birthday the
first year birthday that's kind of it's
for the adults yeah it's for the social
second third fourth and fifth oh I'm not
the fourth maybe they're in the game a
little bit yeah yeah who's conditioned
them that they don't expect anything
good life sucks man life sucks nothing
special about your stupid birthday
everything there's a bunch of people
born on debt that day bunch of people
born tomorrow a bunch of people born
yesterday
get over yourself kid concur four years
old I know a bunch of people who turn
four anyway agree I think that age too
all the way to 21 that's my opinion
those are ones that if they want you
there
you I don't make that a dog's gonna
watch around at her 21st birthday she
better down
Gobbo see not a lot in Kabul you know
that check anyway more yeah chuckle what
do you think about when you don't feel
like getting after it you know I put
this out the other day and I think it's
important all right so rome wasn't built
in a day
we all know that everyone's hears that
but rome also didn't fall apart
overnight either it took hundreds of
years for Rome to reach its peak but it
also took time hundreds of years for
Rome to decay and fall apart and that is
representative of life because you don't
achieve worthwhile goals quickly or
easily they take time they take struggle
they take relentless pursuit day in and
day out that's what it takes but also
things don't usually fall apart quickly
either at least at first it's it's a
slow process a little slip here a little
setback over there a little wearing down
of discipline and will over time that's
the thing success and failure are
generally slow processes either slowly
building things up
or gradually tearing them down and
that's why I say you've got to pay
attention you have to watch you have to
watch every single second because those
seconds they turn into minutes then
minutes turn into hours and hours turn
into days and days turn in to years and
so that second that second that just
went by that counted and so did that
second and so did that one
and in those precious seconds you are
either building or you're decaying you
are either gaining ground or you were
losing ground in that second and in
every second
every second counts
so make every second count
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight
so echo if people want to make it count
for this podcast maybe you could tell
them how they can go ahead and do that
if they want to sure be happy to
actually we talked about origin
why did Pete choose origin as then he
told the story right must be slacking on
the listening on that one nonetheless
makes sense because the origin of all
these all the gear is here in the US
this happens to be but that's a big ding
the origin so what do we make keys out
of say cotton you know okay we'll just
take the cotton grow the cotton in the
US what do they do with the cotton turn
it into yarn they do yeah yeah stuff
diet yeah
turned it into a fabric oh yeah yeah yes
and they do all of that they don't
import it you know from wherever you
know some undisclosed American Haley's
yeah you know so maybe that's why it's
called origin because the origin is a
significant thing right anyway all right
cool
so origin what his origin origin is the
best gear in the world straight-up
objectively not subjectively objectively
I got proof boom so I got a key we went
to this origin immersion camp for
jujitsu origin jujitsu immersion camp no
good fun by the way that was your first
time in the origin D wasn't it
yes I think a back yeah yeah I saw you
with yours
it's cool um yeah so kool Kamp got the
key um then I come home got to by the
way actually I got two key tops one pair
pants oh come home made me want to train
more in the ghee by the way I thought
enough it was the ghee or the camp
we're both probably both yeah anyway so
this whole week a drinky and every
single time I went in someone mentioned
the ghee and it's not like it's pink or
something like that when they're like
hey so put on this key yeah it's normal
you can get the blue I had though I have
the white one and everyone it's like Oh
what's up Jeff Glover was one of them
and this is a person who's like you know
if he says that it's something it's not
like some you know fashion person I
don't like that logo or that's a cool
you know anyway is someone who knows kid
anyway everyone asking like what up with
this geese like going to the ship you
made here I might have lost somebody
because I took real long saying it but
nonetheless it's dope and then another
one was Jeff Higgs we know who that is
Higgs II do you know what that is I sure
do yeah yeah
the person that jaha talks about when he
first started to get introduced to jiu
jitsu the guy who reintroduced to
jujitsu yeah he and I got introduced to
Jiu Jitsu together and then he went out
and trained hard yeah I think it was the
day he got his purple belt his purple
house little I thought I mean we trained
with Master Chief Bailey overseas mm-hmm
that for like three months
mm-hm and then we came back we were in
different part a training for real with
Fabio Santos yeah
and the day he got his purple belt I'm
pretty sure was the day he got his for
well he came to my house and was like
let's go train and I said oh yeah
so think about purple belt versus
wipeout Anaya
a neo triangle armlock yeah you know
everything really a joke and it's kind
of tall - tall strong putting beat down
though you bony like in terms of when
he's impacting you with his elbows yeah
yeah real bony he's hitting me yeah he's
got the bones yeah cutting
yeah he's like his triangle feels like
it's gonna cut your head off
cuz he's bony yeah he knows some good
judo too huh yeah yeah yeah and he and
he's got a real he's got a real he's
always in touch with the whole idea of
using this to effectively defend
yourself in a street scenario that's
always in touch with that yeah he always
adds in a little and if you're in the
street you could do this right here yeah
yeah he's did that I went up to studio
540 yeah for very sure I had to train at
10:00 a.m. I had some stuff I didn't do
and then they're only doing noogie at
the V Studio 540 Higgs is teaching the
class Rob's apps he's the owner or
whatever even he mentioned the gear he's
like what is this yeah well because it's
a different material especially not only
specially made specially woven specially
designed for jiu-jitsu yeah so yeah and
I was like oh yeah that's that origin
stuff don't like that you think I think
I might have won it you know he's the
kind of like yeah 1000 yeah I was like
you don't have this one bro and I just
kept walking you know anyway then
afterward he was afterwards when Higgs
was like he's like this is the I think
he even said this is the most
interesting genius like rubbing it in
his fingers you know when he grabbed my
sleep this is the most interesting you
ever seen something like that you know
when that's the axiom yeah yeah with
gorilla weave yeah cuz they have a
normal purl weave which has like little
tiny pearls yeah yeah American pearl but
the axiom that gorilla weave
was it the dragon weave they both look
very similar yeah but they're both yeah
one of them looks like like it's like
I'm not gonna say velvet I'm not gonna
do that
but it looks like that you know no looks
like diamonds which one was the one
remember we were looking at him and
we're in there saying like like I was
like dang this looks super luxurious
that's not the one I have by the way it
was like this the other one I don't know
which one was which but nonetheless
people seem to like the game and the
pants are dope it has the it's like you
can choose drawstring but it
um like you know like sir shorts yeah
where they have the velcro boom and it's
like fitted they go in sizes like of
your waist it's not just like uh-uh
which actually I'm not against the whole
a 1 a 2 a 3 you know I'm not against
that it's actually it's fine it's cool
super simple but this is good it's like
when you get it you can order yours pant
size mm-hmm so you know when you put it
on it's gonna be dope anyway and it is
dope and you know the public responded
in that way as well
so oh also rash guards t-shirts yeah
we're gonna make a bunch of other stuff
yeah yeah there's some cool stuff on
there and the point is really sure I'm
talking about the guy why because I was
all up in that gay this week and that's
fresh on my mind and it's you know one
of those things that sticks in there um
also at the camp um you know how like
when you give your laundry I only had
that one yeah so you give your laundry
you you're out a ye you can't go to the
next session unless you get another gear
just kind of wasn't really about that
but so I would use them twice in a row
and they dry surprisingly fast it's not
even a surprise they drive fast they're
not a hundred percent cotton they got
polyester I think in there with silver
coated they not not kidding it's
antimicrobial silver coating on it yeah
not like silver you can see it yeah but
yeah that's what we're that's that's the
same thing with mine when I pulled mine
when I pull mine out of the washing
machine after the spin cycle it's almost
dry yeah yeah like a pair of chef's
shorts basically yeah it feels
comfortable it's nice yeah so yeah man
anyway so yeah or origin main like the
state main not Mei n Mei and E so origin
main comm going there there's a lot of
cool stuff on there man a lot of it so
yeah check that one out that's the best
gear in America all made in America best
gear in the world all made in America
also jockle has some supplements so
still on origin me.com right there's a
part and I was because I was looking for
you go on the top there and it's as labs
you click on there boom that's where all
the supplements super krill because
normal meal you mean Jocko Supercross
you couldn't just do the krill oil
couldn't no no no not Supergirl yeah
Supergirl like well I get krill when you
can't super krill one of those deals
super kills got the Cape song cool there
you go and you know joint warfare which
is you know a blend of joint summer
fishing yeah yeah furbishing is the
furbishing a word for refurbishing right
but the refurbishing is just doing it
again right no furbishing yeah and
that's got the things that I would say
yeah of course I mean curcumin
chondroitin and the chondroitin is in
the form of sea cucumber it's sweet
that's where it comes from so yeah well
the the intra not interesting I guess
you could call it layers is this is
exactly what you were taking for years
yeah and you were like yeah guess what
origin in the house let's just make that
yeah yeah yeah well sometimes I have to
combine different things before yeah but
now I don't have to combine anything
anymore they're already combined yeah
we're gonna combine it into one pill
deal yeah boom warfare joint work
against difference you know it's a good
idea to by the way cuz now I got to get
remember when I told the story like you
know when you wake up yeah and my
daughter's you told that story Mary yeah
I'm gonna tell it again so she's to jump
on my back when you're right when you
wake up that's your lease warm that's
when you're trying to warm up and get do
physical so the least warm you'll ever
be just in everyday life is when you
wake up
yeah those first 12 burpees are nor
hardly yeah before you do the that
moment so this is the exact moment when
my daughter you know 40 pounds or so
jumped on my back my shoulders my back
or my shoulders whatever she chose and
you know after I took krill fur I think
it was like five six days boom I could
easily do it I didn't have to like focus
on my form nothing like that now I got
two kids and my daughter who's older is
heavier so not this morning yesterday
morning
like I would grow up for school or
whatever I already have my son he weighs
I don't know how much it weighs but he's
one
I have him she still wants to jump on my
shoulder I have him because he's like oh
and then he sees her jump installation
so basically I'm the what do you call it
the vehicle that they're riding on early
in the morning by the way still no
problem still going strong so yeah man
that's it that's a joint warfare
situation right there and krill supercro
get on it you'll be glad you did
also check out on it dot-com / Jocko
this is where I get my kettlebells and I
meant I mentioned this I got the gorilla
ones 72 pounds so I'm cruising right not
lifting cruising and Jade comes my
brother comes I was like I was like yeah
go check out those new kettlebells I got
and it goes oh yeah yeah those are cool
it's like go ahead pick them up he goes
like kind of heavy you know but I've
been doing kettlebells sounds like now
let me show you what not even warmed up
nothing speaking of krill oil yeah it
was actually really the krill oil
springing into action
really boom I do it and you know had to
show him what up nonetheless that was
done with those kettlebells which are
dope by the way um I'm not gonna say get
to designer ones I'm gonna say that I
think you should but I'm not gonna say
to do that I say go on they're on it
calm / chuckle check it out you like
something get something they got cool
battle ropes in any kind of exercise
stuff like the new stuff functional
training equipment keep your workout
interesting if you care about your
workout to being interesting unlike
choco choco did about that stuff don't
get addicted to the interesting
information like I did I think I'm past
that addiction now but you know you do
run that risk on it calm slash chocolate
that's a good on also good way to
support is when you're buying these
books at choco reviews we didn't review
one today but you know in the future
chuckle might and it has in the past
um I we organize these books by episode
on jakku podcast comic on the top click
on ebooks from podcast boom all in order
to support the podcast click through
there to get them boom it takes you to
Amazon supports the podcast that way
also if you're doing any other shopping
hey feel free if you're gonna buy a new
video camera in the event of your video
camera breaking on the plane when you
check your luggage and the video cameras
in there you want to get another one
boom get it through there all good
big big support on that one what it
seems like an opportune time to talk
about your other video camera sure oh
yeah yeah actually it's a good story
though yeah it's not like a tragic story
which it kind of felt like when you
mentioned it I was like well it brought
me back okay so here's a story we go to
Maine right technically we go to Boston
then drive to me no right so you know to
join to drive in you we rent a car well
you know the car rental place and I have
three bags well you have what one two
yeah two bags so five bags total tutor
bag in my suitcase yeah so five bags
total
I have a big bag with equipment in it
suitcase with you know stuff and closing
whatnot and then the third bag which was
the carry-on bit pretty big
you know most important what's important
has a has an important camera in there
that I use my my favorite camera I have
ever had really good camera um has some
value to it will say and it's a red
camera yet red epic w technic red epic w
yeah it's it's a camera is it the best
you can buy is there one more it depends
on what you mean but best but it's it
yeah there's one sort of level okay well
I'll tell you this ain't cheap no it
ain't cheap at all in some places in the
country you could buy a house for the
cost of this camera yeah so it's an
expensive camera yeah and and you'd
think like okay Echo's gonna take really
good care of it yeah which I do really
that's why I carry it on yeah boom boom
trust anyone touching it he's gonna
carry it with him yeah okay continue so
boom we hit the rental car we got
apparently got five bags to account for
what separate there was no there's some
kind of confusion you know yes there was
yes remember cuz remember when you we
were getting in what was like a
expedition something like that and now
those new ones have that automatic tail
door that goes up yeah and you know what
it was I think there's like a sensor
under the bumper that if you like put
your foot under there it closes like if
you know like a hands-free closing the
door situation so the thing started
closing oh yeah and the girl
the rental girl was trying to save me
yeah and she couldn't yeah it was strong
for her which was kind of funny because
I didn't even care I just kind of like
put my back into it and stopped but I
was watching her kind of chuckling cuz
she's trying to stop it and it wasn't
stopping it was she was looking at she
had a look on her face like I was about
to die yeah like Indiana Jones I was
gonna get my head cut off by the door
slamming shut and I was just kind of
like laughing at the whole situation
yeah but that caused some confusion
apparently it was Leigh you're lying it
was like a little micro emergency that
happened and so I was like boom
flustered but wait what all the bags are
in or not and we're trying to fit
remember cuz we you were trying to get
the seats down yeah there's like maybe
three quasi major things going on no and
you know for the six story I'm just
gonna continue so cool we get it all all
to everyone for us we get it all loaded
and at one point like we're like halfway
up there's a three-hour drive oh by the
way if we don't stop and we did stop so
it was like five hours or something like
that so we stop and I remember him open
up Fried Chicken by the way nonetheless
I had a thought and it was literally
lasted three seconds like I don't really
remember putting my camera bag in the
car but what I'm gonna do not put it in
the car it's like the most important bag
so whatever so we just continue we get
up there and right as we pull into like
park there were times like four hours
later within the backcountry of Maine
yeah like not even knowing the first
time there by the way which I don't know
what that even means but either way
we're there and I'm all pumped up yeah I
couldn't roll cuz my rib us stoked to go
in and see everybody and hang out yeah
you can see everyone's inside the light
of the gym yeah so they can't see that
we're outside yeah so I'm all but I'm
stoked so it's yeah the beginning of the
deal don't venture if you will and right
as we kind of roll to a stop I'm
thinking man did I you know you kind of
count we're here and now you start to
account for it and I don't remember that
stuff so the first thing you do I look
in the back seat cuz that's where it
would have went not there and I'd look
in the back not there you know you get
that cold feeling that just rushes over
your body oh my god so like man so
whatever I tell you and you're like oh
you know get on the phone you know call
the airport in Brad you ever tried
calling the airport yeah yeah hey I told
you this afterwards my opinion was at
that point I was like that thing's gone
100 percent 99 gone yeah 99.999% we
you're never gonna see that thing again
I had already cut it away emotionally
into cash from it and I was kind of
thrown you bones like yeah call the
airport maybe they can help you that was
nice of you
yeah because you really you seem like
you care not necessarily about the
camera necessarily but you cared about
me yeah I really I thought that thing
was gone there's no chance of getting it
back get over it
yeah and I was a little bit I said you
know is there podcast recorded that you
don't have copies up on there yeah and
you should know they're all uploaded
else a good thing yeah yeah cuz we're
never gonna see that thing again
yeah and I was thinking I'll see it
again in three months maybe when they
finally recover it from Austin found
from the Boston Airport by the way or I
get my insurance money for down the line
and they gotta go read go through the
purchase process or we just think
they've got Chuck and but we don't have
it for this trip for sure and later on I
found out or realized that we have the
podcast like SD cards in there so oh we
guess we could I just bought some anyway
nonetheless yeah we get there and I'm
calling the airport and right when the
airport recording picks up yeah I just
get this feeling like oh my gosh I'm
just completely going through the
motions right now no one's gonna pick up
and be like sure I'll look for it yeah I
got it no that's not gonna happen
but I keep calling I'm like I'm not
gonna be the guy who didn't do
everything I can so I'm calling or
whatever meanwhile we gotta go talk to
Pete we gotta you know all this energy
you released me you go hey man go ahead
make these calls like okay cool you hang
out to make this totally worthless
effort because you're never seeing that
thing again I'll go hang out with people
yeah so after like a few minutes that I
go in I'm like you know what let me
whatever let me kind of cut it away as a
saying let me at least embrace the you
know what we're doing go in and you can
kind of casually in a way mention like
hey there's some guys from the police if
that came across casually casually I
shouldn't have made it because I met a
bunch of guys you know everyone's saying
hi and a couple guys yeah yeah we're
cops in Rivia
down in Massachusetts and you know right
by Boston Yeah right next and and I mean
I met them and then you stroll back in
and you met a couple people and then I
said you talk to anybody well yeah I
talked to this and they're gonna look
whatever I'm thinking you how things
gone and I said you know if there's
anyone in the world that could like make
something happen right now
it's cops yeah it's it's cop Boston cops
Revere cops and what and I just said I
said bro and I was a little this is my
ego I was embarrassed for you
I felt bad that you had to go and tell
somebody that you lost this yeah
sick camera and so I just said hey man
those guys over there they're cops and
it was anyone that is gonna get this
thing back it's them
yeah and I'm thinking you know the whole
story we're like did you see this
so did you not think that they were
gonna be able to help I I thought that
they'd be like oh you lost your bag like
everyone does every single day at that
Airport Oh
we're cops bro we have crimes to solve
yeah no I hate your stupid my attitude
of that thing being gone actually
changed as soon as I connected a cinema
self oh they're cops we're gonna we're
gonna turn this over to them and they
can make things happen yeah that's good
and you and even me when I was like okay
I'm gonna mention it to these cops and
these cops are gonna be like like what
do you think our job is you know to go
recover your lost luggage like do three
hours away by the way no so I'm like you
know what Jocko said
do it I'm just gonna do it this is
another go through the motions thing so
I kind of timidly go Dennis and Nate
they were there they just rolled or
whatever and I was like hey I lost the
bet and they were like look what it
looked like like they kind of were into
it I was like oh this is promising you
know like they actually care cuz I was
thinking they'd be like man that's a sad
story bro I'm gonna go talk to Jocko
again you know kind of thing I thought
that was gonna happen and they're like
no bro they get on the phone yeah and
they're like what it look like boom one
more question like well where'd you
leave it
okay boom back on the phone back on the
phone these two guys mic off
this is it's starting to kind of look up
and he's like okay so they hang up the
phone it's just a waiting game now just
a matter of time I got this I got this
guy I'm like for real they're like yeah
man just waiting they called they called
all their browsers out there and there
was like a force of troopers about to
get in there
had that thing recovered in what 20
minutes 20 minutes so we they hang up
and they're like just a matter of time
bro and then we just start talking about
other stuff yeah you know kind of
teasing me a little bit whatever I
deserve it the probably even 10 times up
but and then we're talking about other
stuff boom his phone rings he's on it
he's like is it a mindSHIFT bag and all
this a describing it I don't even know
that's how out of touch I'm like yeah I
think so go inside and he's any any bus
up my laptop or whatever it's matching
the description and in my mind I'm like
there's no way he found it like a cop's
not gonna just roll into the Logan
Airport here and find my bag no way
that's gonna happen but it happened sure
enough he's like oh your fragment cuz it
has a fragment sticker on my only laptop
he's like frag mobiles like that will
call the feeling turned into just warmth
in love and rainbows on this guy's like
that's the one they were like and you
know they're kind of they didn't
actually high-five but they're kind of
like almost like you know this is this
little task they kind of bond to dinner
and just like that 20 minutes man it it
tended to and then one oh who drove it
up um Robbie yeah that's his name right
Robbie show yeah I own him a role
actually there was another guy Callaghan
who was the guy who went and grabbed so
it was like a coordinated deal man and
um man that was like the one of the more
heroic things that has happened to me in
in the recent past
so got the camera back got the camera in
the computer yeah we're good
so in the event so the point is in the
event of you shopping for cameras can't
get a red can't run Amazon but if you
want to get like a Sony HD handicap you
know well whatever you're using cuz it
broke in the luggage I'm not saying that
happened to me I'm just saying if that
ever happens you want to get another one
boom you can go through there chuckle
store calm click through and thanks to
everyone that got that camera back yeah
much appreciate it and the laptop with
all kinds of videos and important stuff
on it yeah actually there's you guys are
on the laptop but but yeah man Denison
Nate the primary guys mr. Callaghan I
didn't meet him but he's done because
you recovered that and then Robbie I owe
you a roll oh you two rules I owe you a
lot yeah man he's the one who delivered
it so big up to all of them big-time so
also back to support of Jocko podcast
subscribe to the podcast iTunes stitcher
Google Play it's a good way to support
kind of kind of kind of obvious like oh
yeah you subscribed already but some
people maybe they didn't maybe they're
just kind of maybe wish not wish wish
but you know kind of still on the fence
we can do it
sure you can unsubscribe if we're not
delivering value I don't like to use
that expression adding value thinks it's
cool I thought it was cool nonetheless
if we're not adding value cannot
subscribe if you want also subscribe on
YouTube what's the recent development Oh
your book mm-hmm disagrees field man
Field Manual which yeah we put a video
on there it kind a little summary mm-hmm
I was real excited to see that video
come out yeah and I was you know we were
texting back and forth and you said well
how about you know we'll put it out
tomorrow but it's ready and I said just
brought out now yeah yeah then you said
launching in three two and the nervous
and I went to my YouTube on my phone and
I was refreshing refreshing refreshing
refreshing refreshing and I wanted to
catch it like the first person to catch
it a refreshing refreshing and this
happened
I got a ping from my mail on my phone
and I switched to mail and it said Jaco
podcasters upload a new video so that's
one of the benefits of subscribed to the
YouTube channel if something comes out
you can have it email you if you want it
to you can have it email you when
something new comes out and otherwise
there's no way you'd know yeah so if you
care about that 10 stuff which you know
it's one of those deals where yeah sure
you get the video version of the podcast
if you care what we look like just fine
actually people play it on their TV like
in their little home gym or something
like that which it's cool it's kind of
like we're all there together you know
yeah and then yes some excerpts in there
the video that you made for the book
yeah I think it might be your best video
ever it might be I think it's up there
man oh yeah let's talk it's real good I
was talking somebody on Facebook and
like oh hey that video is cool and I
thought about saying oh man thanks for
that but I thought about it's like wait
Jaakko kind of did all the work really
you know you're the one working out your
words you saying the words I said all I
did was put some cool music in some
words on there all that other stuff
happened in there the words in the way
it's all coordinated together and all
that stuff so lights up there
nonetheless you know what I'm to be
honest I'm I like how it came out - yeah
it was good III think it might be the
best one
hey man you know it depends on what you
mean by best you know I don't know
impactful sure it's a good one I liked
it yeah he was but if someone who wasn't
subscribed to the YouTube channel yeah
they might not never know that that
video exists that's true and that the
deaths that hurts or no Facebook or no
Twitter or no nothing's yeah yeah so
choose your your well that I tweeted
that one out but I don't always tweet
out when something comes out yeah yeah
that's do you know yeah I don't always
do that sure so if you subscribe you'll
know realest of what my actions are
that's true and you know choose whether
or not you want to alert you know
sometimes you don't want that alert
every single time but sometimes you do
you know I'll put some deleted scenes on
there as well
anyway nonetheless yeah YouTube channel
we have one and it's cool I think it's
cool chocolate eggs it's cool mmm I just
got a
little thing YouTube kind of change
their look on YouTube I don't know if
you noticed that it's hard for me to
judge because I have YouTube red now no
ads red so dope nonetheless I like ads
actually the they did good a good thing
with the ads now now you can click like
I don't like this ad or you can give
that so you can kind of narrow down the
ads you see I like the movie trailer
heads you know like I don't like in the
ads yeah I can watch what I want to
watch everyone else get away from me
yeah yeah I dig it man I dig it fully
well nonetheless point there is
subscribe subscribe to the YouTube
channel is a good way of supporting the
podcast if you want to also chocolate is
the store it's called jaw closed or jaw
closed or calm of course very creative
name by the way I guess technically I
came up with the name yeah you did
just store is their storage ah clothes
store I concurred with the name yeah so
what do we have on the store if you
don't know already
we've got shirts on there rash guards
travel mugs some bumper stickers patches
hats ball cap hats not like did you
bring mine today top hats you don't look
like you did yeah no I didn't bring
yours servo you owe me nine then molest
there on their chocolate or calm I guess
technically you could go to your own
store and get a hat or nine hats as it
keeps me okay I'll do that today thank
you
yes if you want if you want to I'm
swimming stuff on there some hoodies we
want to get a thicker hoodie that's what
we're doing area I know you said you're
the up a bunch of times
mm-hmm but yeah we'll work on that so
there at bloom hoodies I think what
what's the next move what's the next
thing
winter hoodie winter hoodie yeah yeah I
think you should be I think I'm gonna
put a warrior kid rash guard on there
too for for worried kids doing noogie
jiu-jitsu or even gay you know you wear
the rash guard on Jackie sometimes yeah
yeah yeah I think that we do awesome
stuff nonetheless Dunkel store that's
where you get choco stuff
it's pretty cool so I'm not saying to
buy something I'm saying go on there
check it out if you like something get
something good way to support also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is it is an album with tracks
chocolate tracks
it's Jocko saying stuff to you so if you
listen to it it's not like a story right
like a lot you know a lot of times it's
not music obviously it's not Jocko
singing hardcore which you do from time
to time by the way you're variety and
here's a kind of a rhetorical question
okay have you ever ridden not you jungle
but the people out there have you ever
ridden with Jaco for five hour three to
five hours in a car no okay let me tell
you what it's like part of what it's
like
it's Jocko drumming even in the airplane
by the way
drumming on what do you call that the
handle in the door like you're doing
like drums and then singing under his
breath hardcore stuff um what else are
you singing he's like Tom Petty's it was
a pity it was something anyway I have no
idea yeah but it was songs all's I know
is ever occasion I look at you and you'd
be looking like can you please stop yeah
yeah which I got a kick out of him yeah
you would more yeah or stop the car and
like get out or something yeah you get
out and walk yeah yeah drums that was
the look for sure yeah wait no you get
out
stop playing drums and get out does look
nonetheless these tracks are not that
they're him him chaco talking to you
telling you pragmatic ways to get over
your current weakness what weakness okay
so let's say you're trying to stick to a
good diet right trying to wake up early
or all is alright at this moment
actually yeah currently in 48 hours no
currently nope
feeling good too I guess technically I'm
passing too because they ate a salad Oh
hardcore workout so yesterday and today
rolled last night 70 percent ribs a
little tweaked still but Andy Dean light
rolls a little bit with NAMM it goes it
but yeah no laughing the whole time yeah
yeah
yep so technically am i fascinating
fajitas salad at like 11:45 last night
well you know is it I drink some coffee
yeah
fast fast 24-hour fast no no Oh 12-hour
fast no yeah fasting not it moved is
there such thing as an eight hour fast I
think that's just life no for now if
you're not doing if you're not doing at
least 12 hours okay 12 hours is the
cutoff for calling it a minute if I
don't know what the cutoff a stink about
a doctor yeah but you're even a
nutrition well you're fasting right now
currently yeah yeah what if like you
just didn't eat yet whatever it I just
didn't eat yet there's a difference yeah
so what's the difference that's not a
question
no no no hey your your man of humility
say you don't know when you don't know I
like that nonetheless back to
psychological warfare if you're trying
to stay on the fast or wake up early
every morning you know or stick to the
diet stay in the program whatever in
whatever way ways that you have
opportunities to slip this is an album
with tracks that tell you why you
shouldn't slip on you're waking up early
your diet you're working out my whole
thing you know like I said before if I
don't feel like working out I kind of
tend to be like oh maybe I'll rest today
maybe I'll do it later
you know that whole thing not good yeah
this helps with that it'll just tell you
like why you know how in a nutshell
tells you the benefits of not slipping
and the repercussions of slipping that's
it right mattock way but it's Jocko
telling it to you so it works 100% of
the time my experience
speaking of fasting people ask me it's
all time when you're fasting do you eat
anything yeah I do actually
sunflower seeds sunflower seeds because
it takes you like 37 minutes to have one
little tiny seed to get it chewed up and
so but they're but they're good because
they keep you occupied and you're
chewing and they taste good and blah
blah blah
sometimes I'll grab a handful of nuts
just mix nuts just maybe one in the
morning mmm maybe one at night yeah one
handful and jockle white tea boom that's
the things now
I won't eat the nuts but I don't know
III I'm do you got to be careful that
you don't have 13 handfuls of nuts yeah
cuz like I'm just talking like a handful
nuts right
but chocolaty I have that for sure and
you know what if you call me now or you
want to put like oh you weren't really
fasting because you have Chaka white
teen you have a handful of nuts yeah I
mean if you think about the amount of
calories that I burn on a daily basis a
handful of nuts just basically and it's
significant but whatever maybe I'm doing
it wrong that's okay I'm just telling
you what I'm doing I'm not telling you
to do it I'm not telling you to copy
what I'm doing I'm just telling you what
I'm doing right now
don't imitate me go find a professional
to talk about fasting I'm just telling
what I'm doing jakka white tea let me
tell you tastes good feels good and
increases your deadlift about 12 fold or
so yeah so that's real good for you you
can guarantee Amazon also on Amazon you
can get some books extreme ownership
combat leadership I appreciate everyone
that gets it for themselves and then
gets it for their teams and sends
pictures of 47 extreme ownership copy
stacked up I got something else for you
that's awesome
get it for your business associates
people that you work with but they're
not in your company you get it for them
and that's going to improve everything
in your world too because then they
start taking ownership of problems and
everything gets better so no and I've
had a lot of people that have said hey I
gave this to this person I gave this to
this you know partner that I used to
have and now he's got his own business
but we're working together and I gave
him the book and now we're working
together even more mm-hmm so there's a
good idea for you where the warrior kid
this is awesome at the origin camp a
bunch of people from all over the
Northeast brought their kids up to meet
hang out get a signature and all that
and what's cool this is what's cool kids
tell the truth you know I mean they
don't even they're not aware of they
don't care about your feelings at all
yeah and it's awesome to you know say I
always say to kiddo
did you read that book and they go yes I
go how'd you like it and they all say I
love it it's awesome mmm and we know
you're Jocko
and thank you for writing it and those
kids are getting stronger and smarter
and tougher and better so you want to
help out kids that you know get them
this book right here discipline equals
freedom Field Manual that's what it is
it's a Field Manual for those II that
don't know what a field manuals in the
military a field manual is the
instructions on how to do something in
the field whether it's attack a strong
objective or whether it's doing
reconnaissance or how to conduct a
patrol the Field Manual gives you the
instructions on how to do that and
that's what this is the discipline
equals freedom field manual is a field
manual on how to implement discipline
into your life there's zero amount of
fluffin here there's zero there's
nothing in there that you you're gonna
say to yourself well I think jockle
might have just thrown this in here for
you know kind of take up some space in
the pages didn't happen rather not do it
rather burn the whole book it don't care
about that books not long enough cool
read less yeah so that's what it is get
it from your local book store so go down
to the neighborhood book store and tell
them you want this book or you can get
it from Barnes Noble you can get it from
Amazon let them know what's up it's in
the get after it section of your local
book store if they have one if they
don't have that section they need it so
they can put this one book by itself in
they're getting after it your videos
awesome by the way thanks Doug for your
business if you need to help aligning
your leadership and improving the way
that your whole team leads together
check out our leadership and management
consulting company it's called echelon
front me Lafe babban JP Danelle Dave
Burke you can email info at echelon
front calm finally the muster September
14th and 15th I'm pretty sure it's sold
out by the time this podcast comes out
we've been able to squeeze a couple more
people in it each of these even we were
sold out we got in like four more people
three more people seven more people
check might be completely sold out but
extreme ownership calm and it if you
want to we're gonna pretty soon get the
dates for the 2018 musters going so
start looking to that and get registered
as early as you can and until the muster
if you happen to want to keep cruising
with us kind of hard we are on the
interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and
face a ha echo is at Echo Charles and I
am at Jocko willing and finally to the
military members out there sitting on
some forgotten barricade holding the
line to protect us thank you to the vets
that's stood on the wall and did their
time thank you to the police law
enforcement firefighters EMTs other
first responders thank you for what you
do day in and day out and to the rest of
you with goals and dreams and aspiration
make sure you remember that seconds turn
into minutes minutes turned into days
and days turn into years so make those
seconds count
all of them
and until next time this is echo and
Jocko out